ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
HILL.
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
MORE WALK.
AROUND [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RALPH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT
OUR GUEST IN MEMBERS.
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEAD
IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SYSTEM CHAU GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH WILL REMAIN STANDING
AND WILL BILL LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
GALGIANI.
BUT A CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE -- GODS MAY WE FIND AND
PRAISE YOUR GOODNESS DWELLING
WITHIN EVERY HUMAN BEING.
MAY WE BE A LIVING SIGN OF YOUR
GENEROUS LOVE.
AND HELP ALL TO LIVE MORE
INTIMATELY WITH YOU.
MAY WE RESPECT THE EVOLVING
NATURE OF CREATION.
AND GROW TO OUR FULLNESS OF LIFE
WITH YOU.
GUIDE OUR SEARCH INTO THE
MYSTERY OF OUR BEING.
AND LEAD US TO DO HERE WILL.
AND TODAY WE PRAY FOR ALL THOSE
BEGINNING RAMADAN.
MAY THEIR FASTING BRING
BLESSINGS TO THE WHOLE WORLD A
MAN.
HONESTY THAT WE HONOR OUR FALLEN
PEACE OFFICERS AROUND THE STATE
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PRESIDENT
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO AND ONE AND INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY TO THE CORAL.
I DON'T FEAR.
NOW WE DON'T HAVE ROOMS
[inaudible]
CENTER PAN.
ARE YOU READY [inaudible]
FOR IN TUITION.
THE PROVISIONS ON FLOOR
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE ARE A S. C. R..
THIRTY SIX MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR PAN
RELATIVE TO CYSTIC FIBROSIS
AWARENESS MONTH.
SOONER PAN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS OUT TODAY BRING TO U..
S. C. R. THIRTY SIX PROCLAIMING
THE MONTH OF MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
ASSISTS SIX FIBROSIS AWARENESS
MONTH.
CYSTIC FIBROSIS IS A CHRONIC AND
PROGRESSIVE SYSTEMIC DISEASE.
IS THE MOST COMMON FATAL GENETIC
DISEASE IN THE UNITED STATES.
DUE TO PROGRESS IN UNDERSTANDING
THE DISEASE AND NEW THERAPEUTIC
ADVANCES THE AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS OF INDIVIDUALS
RECENTLY DIAGNOSED WITH CYSTIC
FIBROSIS IS NOW IN THE EARLY
FORTIES.
CITY FIBROSIS RESEARCH CONTINUES
FOR POTENTIAL THERAPIES AND A
NATION WIDE NATIONAL WIDE
NETWORK OF CARE CENTERS EXISTS
TO IMPROVE THE LATE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE. FOR INDIVIDUALS CYSTIC
FIBROSIS YET LIGHTS CONTINUE TO
BE LOST. TO THIS DISEASE.
EDUCATION THE PUBLIC ABOUT
CYSTIC FIBROSIS INCLUDING THE
SYMPTOMS OF THE DISEASE
INCREASING KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF SAYS A FIBROSIS.
PROMOTES.
EARLY DIAGNOSIS SUPPORT FOR
THESE IMPACTED BY SIX OF
FIBROSIS A RARE DISEASE BEGINS
WITH RAISING PUBLIC AWARENESS.
PHYSIC FIBROSIS RESEARCH
INCORPORATED CFR I WORKS WITH
THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS COMMUNITY ON
THE BOTH THE STATE AND NATIONAL
LEVEL. TO ADVOCATE FOR CONTINUED
RESEARCH ACCESS TO CARE AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW THERAPIES TO
EXTEND AND ENHANCE LIVES.
CERTAINLY THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS
COMMUNITIES ADVOCACY FOR HIGH
QUALITY CARE IS A MODEL. FOR OUR
COUNTRY TO IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FOR SCO THIRTY SIX
THANK YOU.
THERE'S ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON ESSIE OUR THIRTY
SIX HEARING AND SEEING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE WELL. FIVE GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE OSEM [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible] FIVE
HILL.
I WITH SOME [inaudible] FOR
TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING. FIVE MORE LOT
[inaudible]
HI TOMORROW [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
HI ROB [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
HI STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
DOCTOR PAN MOVES A CALL.
DOCTOR BRAND FOR THE PURPOSE OF
INTRODUCTIONS THANK YOU MATT
MISTER PRESIDENT -- CENTERS
TODAY AND SUPPORT AND THAT'S
YOUR THIRTY SIX I HAVE WITH ME
WE'RE JOINED TOGETHER BY GROUP
OF ADVOCATES FROM C. F. R. I. IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS.
WE HAVE JESSICA MARTINS STACEY
AND MARIO REVELL US MARINO
GONZALEZ.
BATH KELLY LIST MARINO -- FOR
HEART OF DENNIS NILSEN.
MD MARCIA PRIZE JOE DIVO LORETTA
MENDEZ DANNIELLA MANDELA TAKEN
FRAKER AND JULIE DASH MDPLEASE --
WELCOME THEM GIVE THEM A ONE
CENT WELCOME THANK YOU LET'S
GIVE HIM A WARM SAID IT WELCOMED
WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
WE HAVE A
JUST WANNA SAY HI TO
FORMER CONGRESSMAN JIM COSTA.
CURRY **** ROCK ARE SENATOR
FORMER SENATOR HERE.
THE GIVEN THE RUN OF BLOOD.
SENATOR DRAWS ARE YOU READY.
YEAH FROM THE PRO TEM'S US YOURS
.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LET THE NO
[inaudible]
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN ARE ARE
TWENTY NINETEEN LATINO SPIRITS
AWARDS HONOREES.
THESE AWARDS WERE FOUNDED
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO AT THE STATE
CAPITOL TO HIGHLIGHT
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE.
BY LEADERS WITHIN OUR DIVERSE
LATINO COMMUNITY.
AND THEY REPRESENT A SMALL
SAMPLE OF THE GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS
EACH ONE ACCOMPLISH.
THROUGH HARD WORK.
PERSEVERANCE.
BUT ALSO SURROUNDED BY THE
SUPPORT OF THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
I WILL BEGIN BY INTRODUCING A
SPECIAL IN MEMORIAM LATINO
SPIRIT AWARD HONOREE.
HE IS THE FORGOTTEN FOR FATHER
OF UCLA.
FORMER SENATOR AND SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM IN.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO REYNALDO
FRIEND SEES GOAL THEY LIE IN.
LOS ANGELES NATIVE BUT HE NOW
DON'T THEM VIA GREW UP A
BILINGUAL BICULTURAL LET THE YOU
KNOW IN THE NEW U. S. STATE.
CALIFORNIA IN THE LATE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS IN THE LEGISLATURE HE
GUIDED TO FRUITION LEGISLATION
ESTABLISHED SEEN.
LOS ANGELES STATE NORMAL SCHOOL
THAT WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER LEARNING.
IN NINETEEN NINETEEN THE ASSETS
OF THE LA STATE NORMAL SCHOOL
WERE USED TO FOUND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES UCLA.
HE SERVED IN PUBLIC SERVICE
UNTIL.
NINETEEN TWENTY NINE HERE
REPRESENTING THEM VIA IS DOCTOR
HAYES BAUTISTA DAVID HAYES ABOUT
THESE STUFF DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF WHAT THE
YOU KNOW HEALTH AND CULTURE AT-UCLA.
AND CO AUTHOR OF A COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY ON THE LIFE AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF MR THAT VIA.
OUR IN MEMORIAM HONOREE THE
HONORABLE BUT HE NOW DON'T
FRANCISCO THAN BY [inaudible]
REPRESENTATIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR HAYES BOTH
THESE VERY MUCH.
DURING GOOD DOMINGUEZ IS THE
CHAIRWOMAN AND CEO A BANNER
GROUPS OF COMPANIES.
THAT RIGHT. TO READ IS ALSO THE
FOUNDER OF THE DOMINGUEZ DREAM
IN MEMORY OF HER FATHER WHICH
EMPOWERS CHILDREN IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO ACHIEVE IN
LITERACY AND STEAM.
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
ARTS AND MATH.
DURING IS A MINORITY OWNER OF
THE NBA SACRAMENTO KINGS AND HAS
BEEN LISTED BY FORTUNE AS ONE OF
THE FIFTY MOST POWERFUL LET THE
KNOWS.
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OUR BUSINESS AND
PHILANTHROPY HONOR READ MISTER
DOREEN THE MINGUS.
REGARDED AS ONE OF THE FOUNDERS
OF THE FIELD OF MEXICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY INTO GHANA STUDIES IS
ALBERT BELL MOBILE.
HE IS THE FIRST MEXICAN AMERICAN
IN THE NATION'S HISTORY TO
RECEIVE A PHD IN U. S. HISTORY
WITH A SPECIALIZATION IN CHICANO
HISTORY.
HE IS CURRENTLY THE LEON SLOSS
JUNIOR MEMORIAL PROFESSOR AND
PROFESSOR OF AMERICAN HISTORY
EMERITUS AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
HIS STORY CAREER AT STANFORD
BEGAN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WHEN HE WAS APPOINTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HISTORY.
MANY IS THE ONLY FACULTY MEMBER
IN STANFORD HISTORY. TO RECEIVE
SIX OF THE HIGHEST AWARDS FOR
EXCELLENCE IN TEACHING AND
SERVICE TO THE UNIVERSITY.
HE HAS PUBLISHED SEVEN BOOKS AND
DOZENS OF ARTICLES ON THE
HISTORY OF MEXICAN AMERICANS AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
ARE TWENTY NINETEEN ACHIEVEMENT
IN ACADEMIA HONOR READ ALBERT
COME OUT HE'LL.
ASSEMBLYMAN LLOYD IS ABID IS A
RISING STAR IN THE MOVEMENT FOR
GENDER AND SOCIAL JUSTICE IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND THE
SURROUNDING REGION.
SHE CURRENTLY WORKS AS THE
PROGRAM'S MANAGER AT THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS.
CALIFORNIA OFFICE WHERE SHE
WORKS TO ENGAGE AND MOBILIZE
DIVERSE POPULATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO BREAK THAT STIGMA
SURROUNDING MENTAL HEALTH.
AND BECOME ADVOCATES AND
TEACHERS FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES SHE IS A DEDICATED
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
SHE FOUNDED THE STOCKTON YOUNGER
WOMEN'S TASK FORCE WITH THE
VISION TO EMPOWER AND UPLIFT THE
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT DIVERSE
VOICES OF YOUNGER WOMEN.
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN ACHIEVEMENT
IN PUBLIC SERVICE HONOR READ
MISTER LAMB A LOT AS A BEAT.
AND I MUST SAY ON HER BEHALF SHE
IS HERE WITH HER GRANDMOTHER
TODAY.
AND WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HER
AS WELL.
DOCTOR GOURD CARLOS COURT THIS
IS PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF HISTORY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE.
HE HAS LECTURED AND CONSULTED ON
DIVERSITY THROUGHOUT THE U. S.
LATIN AMERICA EUROPEASIA AND
AUSTRALIA HE ALSO SERVES ON THE
FACULTIES OF THE HARVARD
INSTITUTE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE A SUMMER INSTITUTE FOR
INTERCULTURAL COMMUNICATION AND
THE FEDERAL EXECUTIVE INSTITUTE.
DR CORTEZ WAS SCHOLAR IN
RESIDENCE WITH UNIVISION
COMMUNICATIONS AND RECEIVE THE
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND DOUBLE
LATE C. P. IMAGE AWARD FOR BEING
CREATIVE CULTURAL ADVISOR OF
NICKELODEON'S AWARD WINNING
CHILDREN'S TELEVISION SERIES.
DORA THE EXPLORER AND GO THE IT
WILL GO.
HE IS A HIS MANY BOOKS INCLUDING
HIS MEMBUANG.
ROSE HILL ON INTERMARRIAGE
BEFORE ITS TIME.
AND THE FOUR VOLUME
MULTICULTURAL AMERICA MULTI
MULTI MULTIMEDIA ENCYCLOPEDIA
DURING THE PAST YEAR HE HAS BEEN
A FELLOW OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT NATIONAL CENTER
FOR FREE SPEECH AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
OUR HONOR WE IN EDUCATION AND
MEDIA DOCTOR GUARD Là SCORED
THIS.
HIS BILL VIçT.
IS THE FOUNDER OF DEL RECORDS
ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL LATIN
INDEPENDENT ENTERTAINMENT LABELS
AND REGIONAL MEXICAN MUSIC WITH
OVER TWENTY THREE MILLION FANS
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
GAINES IN SPITE OF HIS SUCCESS A
HUMBLE AND STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
GIVING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY HE
HAS DONATED OVER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
AND PROJECTS SUCH AS THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES.
FOR AUTISM RESEARCH AND SUPPORTS
MANY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE NATION
TO PROVIDE FOOD FOR THOSE IN
NEED.
IN TWENTY A TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HE LAUNCHED DEL RECORDS AND HAS
EXPANDED THE BRAND.
A TO INCLUDE PUBLISHING STUDIOS
ENTERTAINMENT AND THEIR FIRST
PODCAST DEL RECORD SUCCESSFUL
ARTIST.
THAT REDEFINED THE REGIONAL
MEXICAN MUSIC JOHN RIGHT BY
TOPPING CHARTS AND WINNING
RECORDS ACROSS THE MUSIC
INDUSTRY.
COLLEAGUES IN THE BUSINESS AND
PHILANTHROPY HONOR READ MISTER
ON HAND THEY'LL BE OUT.
NOW THIS VERY YOUNG MAN.
BORN AND RAISED IN LOS ANGELES
ANTHONY GONZALEZ IS ALREADY AN
AMERICAN ACTOR MUSICIAN WHO
BEGAN PERFORMING AT THE AGE OF
FOUR MOST NOTABLY SOME OF YOU
MIGHT RECOGNIZE HIS VOICE.
HE PLAYED THE LEAD ROLE OF
MIGUEL IN PIXAR'S OSCAR WINNING
INTERNATIONALLY KNOWN ANIMATED
FEATURE COOL COOL. FOR WHICH SHE
WON TEEN CHOICE AND ANNIE AWARDS.
AND THE NAME.
HE ALSO STARRED IN THE FEATURE
ICE BOX WE PATES UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WHO IS DETAINED BY
BORDER PATROL AND DETAILS HIS
EXPERIENCES IN THE U. S.
DETENTION CENTER AND IN OUR
BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
WITHIN HIS COMMUNITY ANTHONY HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN VARIOUS
CHARITABLE CAUSES INCLUDING THE
LEFT ON USA WE DAY AND
MCDONALD'S HOUSTON CHILDREN'S
FESTIVAL HE GREW UP READING IN
UNIVISION'S GLOBE THE LOS
LEAVING THE BILL'S.
A PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO COLD OF
EIGHT THE SPANISH LANGUAGE
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES.
COLLEAGUES ARE DYNAMIC YOUTH
AWARD HONOR READ ANTHONY
GONZALEZ.
HERNANDEZ IS NATIONALLY REGARDED
FOR HER EXPERTISE IN IMMIGRATION
CIVIL RIGHTS AND PHILANTHROPY
AND IT'S BEEN MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES ADVOCATING FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND UP IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
HE HAS SERVED AS PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION ONE OF CELL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST AND MOST
ACTIVE PHILANTHROPIC
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY HAVE GRANTED NEARLY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS WITH A FOCUS ON
HEALTH HOUSING EDUCATION AND
IMMIGRATION.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU PERSONALLY
HOW I MET HER.
SHE HAD BECOME A YOUNG NEW
LAWYER.
SHE SHOWED THE COURAGE ON THE
AUDACITY TO TAKE ON THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT AND AGAIN AND THE
CASE AGAINST THE LA COUNTY
GENERAL HOSPITAL. FOR FORCIBLY
STERILIZING NUMEROUS EMIGRATE
WOMEN WITHOUT CONSENT OR UNDER
DURESS.
THIS HAS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED IN A
DOCUMENT MEANT THREE NO MAS BED
BEDS.
THIS IS WHY SHE IS MY PERSONAL
HERO.
PREVIOUSLY TO THIS HERNANDEZ HAS
BEEN PRESIDENT AND GENERAL
COUNSEL OF MILD IF THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATIONAL FUND.
AND SHE IS A FELLOW OF THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES AND THE AMERICAN LAW
INSTITUTE ARE ACHIEVEMENT AND
PHILANTHROPY HONOR READ MISTER
UNTIL ANYA HERNANDEZ.
THE STELLA ALONE SO IS THE FIRST
LATINA TO CREATE PRODUCE AND
STAR IN HER OWN NETWORK TV
SITCOM TO STELLA WHICH AIRED ON
ABC.
HE PROBABLY HAD AN ALL OUT THE
NO PRIMARY CAST AND HIDE
NUMEROUS LATINO LEAD WRITERS FOR
HER SHOW HE HAS APPEARED ON
NUMEROUS TVSHOWS.
AND A RECURRING HOST ON ABC'S
THE VIEW.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SHE RELEASED
HER FIRST HOUR LONG STAND UP
SPECIAL LOWER CLASS C. ON
NETFLIX AS WELL AS BECOMING THE
FIRST LET THE IN A LEAD.
IN THE DISNEY PIXAR FILM WITH
HER BREAK OUT ROLE AS CREWS AND
I'M ME THIS IN CARS.
THREE IN ADDITION TO WORK IN
ENTERTAINMENT SHE HAS DEVOTED A
LARGE PART OF HER TIME TO BE A
VOICE FOR LATINOS THE
DISENFRANCHISES AND THE UNDER
REPRESENTED.
CURRENTLY SHE IS WRITING A
MEMOIR ABOUT HER LIFE. FOR SIMON
AND SCHUSTER RELEASED TO BE
RELEASED LATER THIS YEAR.
COLLEAGUES ARE ACHIEVEMENT IN
ADVOCACY AND ENTERTAINMENT HONOR
WE MISS THE STELLA ALONE SO
[inaudible]
AND LAST WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
GUESTS JOINING US THIS YEAR HE
SERVED AS AYE KEYNOTE SPEAKER.
UP RICHARD MONTOYA IS CO FOUNDER
OF THE LEGENDARY PERFORMANCE
THREE OH KNOWN AS CULTURE CLASH.
WHOSE WORK IS INTERTWINED WITH
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND DEEPLY HUMAN
PORTRAYED SOME AMERICANS IN THE
MARGINS OF SOCIETY HE IS ALSO
FILMMAKER.
OF WITH THE WARD THE WINNING
WORKS INCLUDING WATER POWER AND
THE YET TO BE RELEASED
DOCUMENTARY CARL CARL'S I'LL LET
US PLAYING WITH FIRE.
HE IS A FIERCE ARTS ADVOCATE
ACTIVIST AUTHOR AND PROUD FATHER
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
SPECIAL GUEST AND FRIEND OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS MISTER RICHARD
MONTOYA.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE A
FINAL ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN LATINO SPIRIT
AWARD HONOREES.
WELCOME TO THE NINE ON A RESERVE
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS WELCOME TO THE
CAPITAL
OUR RECIPIENTS MEMBERS
WE ARE STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR
SENATOR BRADFORD AT THE PRO
TEM'S TO S. BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AS A MEMBER OF THE DIVINE NINE
IT'S WITH GREAT PRIDE THAT I
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO INTRODUCE THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE FAR WEST REGION
OF ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
INCORPORATED.
THESE DISTINGUISHED WOMEN I
INTRODUCED TO YOU ARE VISITING
THE CAPITAL TO PARTICIPATE IN
YOUR TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA A. K. A DAY.
AT THE CAPITOL WHICH HAPPENS TO
BE THE SORORITIES TWENTIETH
ANNUAL.
DAY AT THE CAPITOL VISIT.
TODAY WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED WOMEN ADORNED IN THERE
PEEKING GREEN FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HERE TODAY
AT OUR CAPITAL.
THE ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
IS THE OLDEST GREEK LETTER
SERVICE ORGANIZATION IS DOLLARS
BY AFRICAN AMERICAN COLLEGE
EDUCATED WOMEN.
IT WAS FOUNDED ON AND ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH IN NINETEEN OH EIGHT
AT HOWARD UNIVERSITY IN
WASHINGTON DC AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN IT
CELEBRATES IT'S A HUNDRED AND
ELEVENTH.
YEAR OF SERVING ALL MANKIND
THROUGH INTERNATIONAL PROGRAMS
OF SERVICE THIS ORGANIZATIONS
PROGRAMS PROGRAMMING FOCUSES ON
EDUCATION.
HEALTH FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
THESE WOMEN A SYMBOL AT THE
CAPITOL EVERY YEAR BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS INPUT PLUS
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY.
THIS DISTINGUISHED SORORITY HAS
PRODUCED LEADERS AND PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR AS WELL AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS MANY OF WHOM
YOU KNOW.
FORMER ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN ONE NEED A MILLER
MCDONALD WHO IS ALSO MY BOSS.
AND MENTOR FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN
FORMER STATE SENATOR AND FORMER
BASS AMBASSADOR DIANE WATSON OR
BOTH DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF
THIS ORGANIZATION.
HERE ARE A FEW MORE NOTABLE
WOMEN THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD
OF FORMER US SUPERVISOR AND
CONGRESS WOMAN YVONNE BRATHWAITE
BURKE WHO ALSO HAPPENS TO BE THE
MOTHER.
OF ASSEMBLY IN PERSON AUTUMN
BURKE.
U. S. SENATOR COM LET HARRIS
[inaudible]
RENOWNED ARTHUR [inaudible]
TONI MORRISON.
STILL RIGHTS ICON CORRETA SCOTT
KING.
THE MOTHER OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
MISS ROSA PARKS.
FILM PRODUCER DIRECTOR OF SELMA
AND THIRTEEN A MADERA BEAR BUT
NAY.
US SINGER AND SONGWRITER ALICIA
KEYS JAZZ PIONEER AND SINGER
ELLA FITZGERALD.
ARTHUR EMPLOYED MY ANGELO.
AND MY FORMER LET'S DIRECTOR.
HUNDRED IT GIVES ME GREAT
PLEASURE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CAUCUS WOMEN OF THE FAR WEST
WEST REGION OF ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
LEADERSHIP.
TWENTY SIX UNDERGRADUATE
CHAPTERS IN FORTY FOUR GRADUATE
CHAPTERS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CENTERS PLEASE HELP
ME GIVE A WARM OUR A RECOGNITION
TO THE LEADERS OF WHO ARE HERE
TODAY ON THE FLOOR.
MISS PATRICE MARSHON MCKENZIE
LEGISLATIVE WHAT ALEJO'S ON MS
LESLIE HIM TEN SEND A CALIFORNIA
STATE COORDINATOR.
MR FARI MY ROLE FAR WESTERN
REGION OR ME REPRESENTATIVE TO
THE INTERNATIONAL CONNECTION
COMMITTEE.
MR RENE THEORY JONES PROTOCOL
OFFICER MISS CAROL OUR DIXON FOR
WESTERN REGION DIRECTOR AND ALSO
THE LADY STANDING IN THE GALLERY
LET'S GIVE A WARM SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
I MENTIONED TO RECOGNIZE ONE OF
OUR GREAT STUDENT EMPLOYEES.
MISS THE AIMS TO LOOK AFTER IS
EVERY DAY DURING GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO AS A KID
.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR THAT SENATOR
NIELSEN CAN DO IN A JOURNEY
MEMORY OF STEVE DIXON.
SENATOR NIELSEN AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE.
WE'RE HERE.
TO THE GERMAN MEMORY AN HONOR
ONE OF OUR OWN.
WITH US HERE TODAY.
OF THE MOTHER.
OF STEPHEN DIXON [inaudible]
PATSY.
HER SON ANTHONY.
THE PASTOR DAVID SEMANSKY IMPALA
BUCKINGHAM [inaudible]
STEVE.
CAME TO ME MANY YEARS AGO.
AS AN ASSEMBLY FELLOW.
HAVING INTERVIEWED HIM BUT FOR A
MOMENT OR TWO I KNOW HE WAS THE
ONE THAT I HOPED.
WOULD BE PLACED.
AND MY OFFICE.
AFTER HE COMPLETION.
OF HIS TIME [inaudible]
THE FELLOWSHIP.
I WAS ABLE TO FIND A PLACE.
ON MY STAFF. FOR STEVE DIXON.
OVER THE YEARS HE WAS A
MAGNIFICENT [inaudible]
EMPLOYEE.
BUT IT ALREADY HAD [inaudible]
AN ACCOMPLISHED [inaudible]
CAREER [inaudible]
IN EDUCATION.
THE HUMBLE STATE UNIVERSITY.
RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
HE DID GRADUATE STUDIES IN
ECONOMICS [inaudible]
AT HUMBLE STATE.
AND AT JOHN HOPKINS.
ALL BEFORE YOU CAME HERE.
HE ALSO HAD A CONSULTING
BUSINESS.
UP ON THE NORTH COAST.
THAT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN MANY THINGS
IN HIS COMMUNITY.
THE RECORD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THE FINANCE ADVISORY BOARD FOR
THE CITY.
THE HUMBOLDT HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMISSION.
IN A HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY.
SENATE DEBATE TEAM [inaudible]
ALSO.
A GREAT INTEREST.
HE BECAME AN APPOINTEE.
OF GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER. TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TRUSTEES.
WHERE HE SERVED?
WITH ONE OF OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES FOR MERENDA WHO WILL
BE SPEAKING A LITTLE BIT LATER.
AND WHO GOT TO KNOW THIS MAN.
IN A VERY DIFFERENT WAY THAN I
STEVE.
HAD A LIFELONG PROBLEM.
WITH HIS KIDNEYS AND HAD AFTER
THE KIDNEY TRANSPLANT.
WAS SUCCESSFUL OF FOR AWHILE BUT
THEN IT BEGAN TO FAIL THAT HE
HAD TO GO ON DIALYSIS.
ANY HAVE REPEATEDLY WAS GETTING
INFECTIONS.
IT WOULD TAKE HIM OFF THE LINE
FOR BUT A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
BECAME A LITTLE BIT MORE SERIOUS.
THEN ONE DAY I WAS UP IN.
THE SUTTER BUTTES.
THE OPENING DAY OF DUCK SEASON I
GOT AN URGENT CALL FROM ONE OF
MY STAFF [inaudible]
AGREEMENT [inaudible]
THAT STEVE [inaudible]
WAS UNCONSCIOUS.
IN THE HOSPITAL IN SACRAMENTO
AND MAY NOT HAVE LONG TO LIVE.
SO I RUSHED DOWN HERE IN THE
PAST SHE WAS THERE MARY THE
DOCTOR.
I CAME INTO THE I SEE YOU AND
CAME UP TO STEVEN I PUT MY ARM.
BYRIDER ARMENDARIZ NECK.
BUT MY FACE.
RIGHT DOWN CLOSE TO HIS.
THE STEVE JOBS I'M HERE STATE.
YOUR MOTHER'S HERE WITH YOU.
MARY SHARE WITH YOU.
THIS IS JIM DON'T TALK JUST
LISTEN TO ME I WANT TO PRAY WITH
YOU.
AND I DID.
IN A LITTLE WHILE.
HIS EYES.
BEGAN TO FLICKER.
ANY LIFTED HIS RIGHT ARM.
WHICH WAS A MASHED IN.
ALL KINDS OF TROOPS [inaudible]
THE NEEDLES.
AND HE DID THIS.
WHEN HE CAME BACK?
THAT WAS -- MIRACLE WROUGHT BY
ME THAT WAS A TERMINATION OF
THAT MAN AND WHATEVER THEY WERE
DOING FOR HIM AT THE HOSPITAL.
ANY HAD SEVERAL MORE VISITATIONS.
OF THOSE CHALLENGES.
THEY NEVER GAVE UP.
AND WE KEPT HIM ON STAFF.
BECAUSE ALWAYS WANTED HIM TO
KNOW HE HAD A PLACE TO COME BACK.
TO A PURPOSE IN LIFE.
THEY DID MANY TIMES [inaudible]
COME BACK.
MANY CONTRIBUTED SOBRE MANY
AREAS THAT WE ALL OF US HERE ARE
INVOLVED IN.
HE WOULD ALWAYS GET UP TO SPEED.
IN THE SHORTEST PERIOD OF TIME.
GIVE US THE BEST ADVICE.
IN A WAY IN [inaudible]
EVEN COACHED [inaudible]
BASEBALL.
YES THE BRIDGE BROTHER EVEN.
HERE'S AN ALL AROUND.
GOOD HEARTED MAN.
PRETTY HUSKY GUY.
BUT HIS HEART WAS BIGGER.
THEN HIS BODY.
A TICKET BRAIN WAS BIGGER THAN
BOTH.
ALWAYS KIND OF FELT A LITTLE
INTIMIDATED.
WHAT'S THE WAS AROUND.
FIGURED HE WAS SMARTER THAN I
WAS.
BUT THAT'S THE BEST KIND OF GUY
TO HAVE WORKING WITH YOU.
IT WAS HARD FOR ALL OF US TO TO
WATCH HIM DECLINE A LITTLE BIT
BUT THEN THEY WOULD.
COME BACK [inaudible]
STRONG.
START TO REGAIN HIS HEALTH.
LITTLE BIT AWAIT.
THEN IT WOULD SLIP OFF TRACK
AGAIN.
AND FINALLY I THINK.
PROBABLY THE GREATEST THING THAT
CARRIED HIM THROUGH WHICH IS
STRONG AND PROFOUND FAITH.
HE ALWAYS SPOKE ABOUT IT.
AND THEN NOT VERY LONG AGO.
LESS THAN A MONTH.
HE SAID JIM I THINK IT'S TIME.
IT HAD THIS CONVERSATION IS OF
THE LORD.
THEN HE WAS READY TO MOVE ON
AGAIN IT WAS VERY HARD ON US
[inaudible]
BUT AGAIN.
WHAT WE CAN DO?
LIVE OUR OWN LIVES ON JUST A
LITTLE BIT LONGER. TO HONOR THE
KIND OF PERSON THAT HE WAS.
THE KIND OF DIGNITY THAT HE FROM
WAS FOR STANDPOINT OF A STAFF
MEMBER.
IN THE SENATE FELLOW
[inaudible]
GAVE.
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
AND THE STATE SENATE.
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN THE
MEMORY.
A STEVEN JAMES DIXON.
THINKCENTRE NIELSEN ON THIS
MEASURES WHILE SENATOR GLAZERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- A STEVE
DIXON WAS A FRIEND OF MINE --
AND HE WAS CERTAINLY WAS A
FRIEND OF SO MANY -- HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL UNDER THE STONE.
I ENJOYED THE TIME WE SPENT
TOGETHER ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AT THE STATE UNIVERSITY
HE WAS SUCH A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE. FOR STUDENTS AND AT
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM HE
CONTINUED HIS WHOLE LIFE TO
PURSUE ADVANCED STUDIES HE HE
LOVED EDUCATION HE LEVEL
LEARNING.
AND HE WAS A GREAT PARTNER.
IN THE WORK THAT WE DID ON THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
WHEN NOT STAFFERS WERE ASKED
HERE IN THE BUILDING?
TO VOLUNTEER CATASTROPHIC
MEDICALLY FOR STEVE.
HUNDREDS OF HOURS WERE DONATED
SHOWS YOU.
HOW MUCH LOVE THERE WAS HERE IN
THE BUILDING FOR STEVE
[inaudible]
HI.
HE HAS MANY FRIENDS NO FRIEND
GREATER THAN THE SENATOR FROM
HANNAH. FOR MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT HE SHARED TODAY
[inaudible]
BUT THE HE STEVE -- WAS A
SPECIAL PERSON.
AND I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
FROM TAMAR SEEIN IT.
NURTURING IT SUPPORTING HIM IN
SO MANY WAYS SO TO HIS FAMILY
HIS BROTHER WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
HE LIVED A LIFE WAY TOO SHORT.
BUT IS IMPACTS WERE NUMEROUS HE
MADE SO MANY FRIENDS HERE.
AND I KNOW AT OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING AS WELL -- WE MISS HIM.
AND IT'S WITH SADNESS -- BUT
GREAT JOY IN THE LIFE THAT HE
DID LEAVE THAT I JOIN IN ASKING
THAT WE ADJOURN HIS MEMORY TODAY
THANK YOU.
YOUR NIELSEN IF I MAY MISTER
PRESIDENT BEHALF OF SENATOR
GLACIER AND MYSELF WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT. ONE OF OUR SENATE
MEMORIAL RESOLUTIONS TO THE
FAMILY.
WHERE THEY CAN REMEMBER HIM?
AND MORE INTERESTING KNOWLEDGE
TO THEM.
THE WAY THE STATE SENATE.
REMEMBER STING DIXON.
RESPECT HIM AND WILL HONOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE FAMILY WE EXTEND
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO STEVE
DIXON AND BRING THE NAME FOR IT
SO IT CAN BE PROPERTY
MEMORIALIZE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RETURNING YOUR PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR NELSON.
THIS PRESERVATION OF THE SENATE.
I PRESENT FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THE SUPPORT.
S. C. R..
FORTY TO US SIX CENTER -- YOU
DIDN'T READ IT YES MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU READ A C. R..
FORTY TWO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
NIELSEN RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER APPRECIATION MONTH
AND CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
MEMORIAL DAY.
WELL MORE THAN EVER BEFORE THIS
YEAR I BELIEVE WE ALL OUR
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS.
OUR HEARTFELT APPRECIATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS.
RESOLUTION DOES THAT KNOWLEDGE
IS.
CALIFORNIA'S.
FIREFIGHTERS OUR APPRECIATION.
AND THEN WE WILL ALSO BE
RECOGNIZING IN THE SHORT TIME
SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS MEMORIAL DAY.
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH IS.
MEMORIALIZED IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
IS A VERY TRAGIC.
IN A VERY HEROIC DAY.
AND I SUBMIT THAT OVER THE LAST.
COUPLE OF YEARS PARTICULAR LAST
YEAR.
OUR CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS MANY
OF WHOM WORE.
IN NEW YORK. FOR THAT TRAGEDY.
BUT THEY ARE FOUGHT AT THE FRONT
LINES HERE.
THE TRAGEDIES THAT WE HAVE
SUFFERED.
MOST ALL OF US IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SOME OF US VERY SERIOUS
[inaudible]
DISASTERS. FOR THESE
FIREFIGHTERS WHO ARE TRAINED.
THE DELIVER EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE.
WHO ARE TRYING TO PUT OUT FIRES?
BUT A LITTLE LOAN PART OF THEIR
JOB IS TO PREVENT.
AND TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
CITIZENS.
THE DO INSPECTIONS IN OUR HOMES.
IN OUR BUSINESSES. TO ENSURE WE
DO NOT HAVE [inaudible]
THOSE FIRES.
IT NOW WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZING HE NEED.
TO PAY HEED TO ARE FORCED AND
OUR WILD LANDS IN URBAN
INTERFACES.
THEIR JOB IS GOING TO BE
EXPANDING EVEN MORE.
TOWARDS THE PREVENTION.
SIDE OF THE EQUATION.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN.
GIVE OF THEIR LIVES.
AND MANY TIMES AFTER SPEND MANY
WEEKS AS IT DID LAST YEAR.
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
SIXTEEN OF THEM [inaudible]
WERE LOST [inaudible]
AND FIRES.
JUST LAST YEAR.
IN THE ROSE GARDEN THIS CAPITOL
GROUNDS.
THERE'S A MEMORIAL HONORING THEM.
AND AS NOTED IN SEPTEMBER.
WE'LL BE RECOGNIZING THOSE WHO
UNFORTUNATELY LOST THEIR LIVES.
THIS YEAR.
BUT THIS IS A REMINDER TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE CRITICAL VALUE.
THESE MEN AND WOMEN DEDICATE
THEIR LIVES.
TO THEY LIKE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS.
WHEN THE KISS THEIR WIVES OR
HUSBANDS?
HUG THEIR CHILDREN AS THEY GO
OFF TO WORK.
THEY NEVER KNOW WHAT THAT DAY
WILL HOLD [inaudible]
BUT BRAVELY.
THEY ASSUME THEIR DUTIES.
MAN THEIR FIRE LINES IN THEIR
ENGINES.
AND THEIR EQUIPMENT.
AND PROTECT US.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME TO THE FLOOR
HERE TODAY IF I MAY.
MISTER MIKE FAY SACRAMENTO AREA
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL.
FIVE TWO TWO BRIAN RICE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
FOUNDATION.
AND RICK MARTINEZ WHO'S ALSO A
PART OF THE FOUNDATION VINCE
WELLS HE'S A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF THAT FOUNDATION.
J. R. HORAS.
ALSO ON THE FOUNDATION MIKE
LOPEZ A LONGTIME FRIEND OF MINE.
THE PART OF THE FOUNDATION
[inaudible]
ELENA REACHED.
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE FOUNDATION SHERA
ROGERS PROGRAM MANAGER FIRE
FOUNDATION.
AND BRITNEY TODO PROGRAM MANAGER
CALIFORNIA FIRE [inaudible]
FOUNDATION.
IT ON YOUR BEHALF LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE.
I BLESSED AND PRIVILEGED TO
PRESENT THEM WITH A RESOLUTION.
COMMENDING THEM FOR THEIR
SERVICE TO ALL OF THE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
AND OUR OWN FAMILIES.
AND THANKING THEM. FOR WHAT THEY
DO [inaudible]
IS.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
YES SENATOR.
JACKSON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AND I KNOW ON BEHALF
OF MANY OF US WHO.
WERE ABLE TO SURVIVE THE FIRES
THAT HAVE TAKEN OVER THE STATE
IN SO MANY AREAS.
I WANT TO THANK THESE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO REALLY ARE.
EXTRAORDINARY HEROES WHO RUSH
INTO BURNING BUILDINGS.
DEAL WITH WILDFIRES OUR
TEMPERATURES WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE.
BUT I THINK WE ALSO OWE IT TO
THEM.
AS LEGISLATORS TO COMMIT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THESE KINDS OF
EVENTS ARE GOING TO OCCUR.
IN THE FUTURE AND SO I'M SURE OF
THAT I CAN SAY ON BEHALF OF MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY
THERE WE WILL RE COMMIT TO YOU.
THAT WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
THESE KINDS OF OF FIRES AN
OFFENSE THAT PUT YOU IN HARM'S
WAY.
AND THE FORCE YOU TO GO OUT AND
TO SAVE OUR COMMUNITIES FROM THE
KINDS OF EVENTS THAT HAVE
CREATED THE HORRORS OF THE GREAT
FEAR WITHIN US ALL.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO AND I
THINK WE CAN PROMISE THAT AND WE
COMMIT TO DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN. TO MAKING YOUR JOBS IN THIS
YOUR LIFE EASIER THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HERE IN NC NINE A CENTER AND
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AFTER THAT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE WELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A I DON'T [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
GROSS [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
I TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible] FIVE LEYVA.
I REQUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK.
I ROOM.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
HI MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER.
I HILL.
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND LET'S GIVE A WARM SENATE
WELCOME TO ALL OUR DEDICATED
FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
.
STILL UNDER PERMITTED FOR
SENATOR GROVE IF YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MY DAUGHTER KRISTIN AND
HER NONPROFIT FOUNDATION
BUSINESS -- PARTNER TIARA KING
THERE UP IN THE GALLERY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THEY'RE THE FOUNDERS OF RETRAIN
THE NIGHT AND AFTER WORKING
SEVERAL YEARS IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INDUSTRY TRYING TO
GET WOMEN RESCUED OUT OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THEY CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA THAT
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IS STOP
SOMEONE FROM PURCHASING ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING FOR SEX.
SO THEY DIFFER SO DEVELOPED
RETRAIN THE NIGHT IN ITS MISSION
IS TO CHANGE NOT ONLY THE HEARTS
AND MINDS.
BUT OF THE MEN WHO OR WOMEN THAT
PURCHASE HUMAN BEINGS FOR SEX.
BUT THEY COME UP WITH THE
CURRICULUM THROUGH
REHABILITATION STUDY IN MENTOR
SHIP.
AND TO HAVE PEOPLE HONOR WOMEN
AND INDIVIDUALS AS REAL HUMAN
BEINGS AND SO THEY'RE YOUNG
THEY'RE DEDICATED THEIR HARD
WORKING AND I'M JUST PROUD THAT
THEY'RE HERE IN TH CAPITAL
TODAY SO PLEASE WELCOME THEM.
THE TO GIVE A WARM SENATE
WELCOME THANK YOU LADY FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
NEXT UP SOONER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AS YOU KNOW TODAY'S THE ANNUAL
CELEBRATION OF LIFE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS.
WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PROTECTING THE
REST OF US?
THE ABILITY TO HONOR THEIR
MEMORY AND THEIR SURVIVORS IS
BECAUSE OF THE GENEROSITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS
MEMORIAL FOUNDATION.
AND THEIR PARTNERS ONE OF THOSE
WE RECOGNIZE TODAY IS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF HELICOPTERS
TO CALIFORNIA'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING OUR VERY OWN
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
WITH THIS IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
IS CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
ROMAINE TRAP AND VICE PRESIDENTS
TRADE MANNING AND ANTHONY BAKER
WHO HAVE COME FROM AIRBUS
HELICOPTERS DALLAS HEADQUARTERS
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THEM.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. FOR YOUR SERVICE.
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PRIVILEGES FROM FLOOR WERE
RETURNING NOW THE MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATOR JACKSON S. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
REQUEST REMOVAL OF SB ONE
SEVENTY SIX FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IT IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
COOLEY NO QUESTION REMOVAL FROM
THE CONSENT CAN REALLY MAKE YOU
THINK YOU.
NOW MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF A
DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR BENHAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT
SENATE BILL THREE OH THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THREE FORTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS SIX FIFTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATE THIRD READING WE HAVE
ITEMS ELIGIBLE SO.
FIRST UP WE HAVE SENATOR WOKE OR
YOU'RE PREPARED FOR YOUR ITEM.
SORRY CENTER WOKE.
DOCTOR PAN I'M SORRY.
BASS ON FILE.
OKAY NEXT UP -- SENATOR RUBIO --
ESSIE OUR THIRTY FIVE ARE YOU
PREPARED TO WOULD DRIVE.
YES MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO STATE SCIENTISTS DAY.
PRESIDENT A MEMBER IS TODAY I
STAND TO RESENT THAT C..
R. S. C. R. THIRTY FIVE WHICH
RECOGNIZES MAY EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN OF THE THIRTY FIRST
ANNUAL STATE SCIENTISTS STATE
AND WOULD DECLARE THAT THIS
STATION BE A TRIBUTE TO THE
DEDICATION AND PROFESSIONALISM.
OF THE STATE'S SCIENTISTS WORK
ON BEHALF OF ALL RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS RESOLUTION IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS AN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND HIGHLY
EDUCATED SPECIALLY TRAINED STATE
EMPLOYED.
SCIENTISTS DATA SHOWS THAT WE
HAVE OVER THREE THOUSAND
SCIENTISTS AND OVER THIRTY STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND EIGHTY ONE
SCIENTIFIC CLASSIFICATIONS TO
PROTECT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FROM LIFE THREATENING.
DISEASES WILDLIFE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AS WELL AS TO PROTECT
OUR AIR AND WATER FROM TOXIC
WASTE AND POLLUTION. FOR THE
PAST THIRTY ONE YEARS STATE
SCIENTISTS HAVE COME TOGETHER TO
SHOW THIRD THROUGH SIXTH GRADERS
STUDENTS WITH REAL LIFE BOB
SCIENTIFIC WHAT THE DAY OF
ENTERTAINING AND EDUCATING OVER
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
OVER. FORTY HANDS ON SCIENCE
EXHIBITS STATE SCIENTISTS HOST
THIS ANNUAL EVENT AT THE STATE
CAPITOL TO INCREASE PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND RECOGNITION OF THE
SIGNIFICANT.
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY SCIENTISTS
WORKING IN STATE GOVERNMENT THIS
YEAR THE EVENT WILL BE HELD ON
WEDNESDAY MAY EIGHTH.
ON THE WEST UP TO THE CAPITOL
WITH THIS IN MIND PLEASE JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING ESSIE OUR THIRTY
FIVE AS THE THIRTY FIRST ANNUAL
STATE SCIENTISTS DATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING TEEN -- NINE THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF SEE. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO.
NEXT UP IS DOCTOR PAN.
BASS ON FILE NEXT UP SOONER
LEYVA.
PASS ON FILE -- NICK SHOPS
SENATOR CAPPIELLO.
PASS ON FILE.
SENATOR WINNER.
SB.
ONE THIRTY SIX PASS ON FILE
[inaudible]
SOONER JACKSON.
PASS ON FILE [inaudible]
OKAY.
BACK TO SENATOR RUBIO ON SB --
THREE SIXTEEN TO TAKE UP THAT I
DON'T.
HOUSE ON FILE.
EXCEPT DOCTOR PAN SB THREE FOUR
THREE DO WE HAVE A WINNER HERE.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
DR GRANT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SB FIVE
THREE FORTY THREE THE BILL THAT
REMOVES PROVISIONS IN THE LAW
THAT ALLOWS KAISER PERMANENTE A
TO REPORT.
LESS INFORMATION TO REGULATORS
AND OTHER HEALTH PLANS AND
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE.
TRANSPARENCY LAWS LIKE GREAT
REVIEW IN HOSPITAL FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURES WERE CREATED TO HELP
PURCHASERS AND REGULATORS
MONITOR ACOSTA DRIVE HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM RATES.
AS HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE TO
RISE POLICYMAKERS PURCHASERS IN
CONSUMERS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
IS DRIVING COST INCREASES AT
KAISER IS HEY HAVE ABOUT EVERY
OTHER HOSPITAL AND HEALTH PLAN.
AS I STATED IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH KAISER ON
REASONABLE AMENDMENTS TO
ACCOMMODATE LEGITIMATE BARRIERS
TO REPORTING THIS INFORMATION.
BY STAFF AND SPONSORS HAVE HAD A
GOOD MEETING WITH KAISER EARLY
LAST WEEK AND WE LOOK CONTINUE
FOR TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM AS PART
OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
NEGOTIATIONS.
IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD FROM
THIS FLOOR BUT THAT EXPECT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
I LOVE THIS BILL AND I LOVE
KAISER BUT WHAT I FELT VERY
FRUSTRATING AS A NEGOTIATOR IS
THAT WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO SET
RATES.
OF FOR OUR MEMBERS IN HEALTHCARE
KAISER WOULD ALWAYS REFER TO A
BLACK BOX AND WE WOULD ASK THEM
WELL WHY ARE YOU CHARGING THE
RATES THAT YOU'RE CHARGING.
THEY WOULD SAY YOU KNOW ISN'T IT
THE EXPERIENCE RATE TO HAVE MORE
OR LESS MEMBERS WERE THERE
CATASTROPHIC ILLNESS WHAT IS
DRIVING THE COST WE COULD NEVER
GET A STRAIGHT ANSWER OTHER THAN
IT WAS IN THE BLACK BOX.
WHAT MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO DO OUR JOB TO NOT ONLY
NEGOTIATE WITH THEM BUT
NEGOTIATE WITH OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS SO I WANT THINK CENTER
PAN FOR BRING IT FORWARD AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT
TODAY?
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN UNDER COMMAND WHICH
ELECT CLOSE I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WANT TO BE CLEAR
KAISER IS A MODEL SYSTEM IN MANY
RESPECTS AND I HAVE NO INTEREST
IN ATTACKING.
KAISER'S -- INTEGRATED SYSTEMS
CARE SYSTEM CARE THAT ACTUALLY
IS BEING EMULATED BY MANY OTHER --
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH PLANS IN
FACT I APPLAUDED AND AGAIN I
WANT TO STATE THAT I REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH KAISER
AND WE ARE TO DEBATE.
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
AMENDMENTS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD HOWEVER I FEEL THAT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE NEED TO
CONTINUE MOVE THIS BILL.
FOR TWO AND THAT SO THAT
DISCOMFORT CONVERSE THE
CONVERSATION CAN'T COME TO A
MEANINGFUL -- RESOLUTION SO WITH
THAT EXPECT THE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
[inaudible]
NINETY EIGHTEEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST. FOR JUST NOW
BRADFORD HI.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
I THEY'RE AWESOME.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROSS.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO ROOM [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO HAN.
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I LIKE HOW SKI [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
HI WELL.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
WELL.
MEASURE PASSED TWENTY SIX NOT A
TWENTY SIX YES. NINE KNOWS
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM NINETEEN SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE NEXT UP IS ITEM
TWENTY ONE SENATOR BILL
[inaudible]
BE PREPARED. FOR THIS I DON'T.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RICK.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY BY
SENATOR WELL RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
MONTH.
SENATE BILL WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES MANSON NATIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH --
THERE WILL BE ALL SORTS OF
ACTIVITIES -- THIS MONTH IN
AROUND THE CAPITAL IN IN YOUR
DISTRICTS -- SO I MASS IN THE
MEMBERS TO PLEASE -- CONSIDER
PARTICIPATING IN THESE
ACTIVITIES IT'S SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE MEN OF MENTAL HEALTH --
ISSUES AFFECT ALL PEOPLE ONE IN
SIX CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCED
SOME MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE AND ONE
OUT OF EVERY TWENTY FOUR HAVE A
MENTAL ILLNESS SO SERIOUS IT IS
BECOMES DIFFICULT. FOR THEM TO
FUNCTION IN THEIR DAILY LIVES
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS COST --
ONE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LOST EARNINGS --
PER YEAR.
AND STIGMA OR AS I CALL IT JUST
DISCRIMINATION ASSOCIATED WITH
MENTAL HEALTH.
ILLNESSES PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM
SEEKING CARE OR FINDING CARE.
WHEN PEOPLE DO SEE CARE THEY
OFTEN ENCOUNTERED DELAYS AND
BARRIERS TO ACCESS?
MANY INDIVIDUALS AND LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES DO NOT
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE CARE.
DO THESE BARRIERS AND LACK OF
ACCESS TO RESOURCES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT A THIRD OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE HAVE SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS IS ESTIMATED THAT
70%.
OF ALL USE IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAVE AT LEAST ONE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION AND 20%
LIVE WHERE SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE MUST -- PROVIDE ADEQUATE.
ACCESSIBLE AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BRING AWARENESS
AND SAVE LIVES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING THIS MONTH MAY AS
NATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
MONTH.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SENATOR OCULATA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND AS A CO AUTHOR OF
THE MEASURE.
AS I HAVE ALREADY HEARD WE HAVE
ALREADY HEARD TOO MANY AMERICANS
SUFFER FROM MENTAL HEALTH.
AND WE MUST ACT IMMEDIATELY I
RISE AS CHAIR OF THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND ALSO
RECOGNIZES JUST TOO MANY
VETERANS WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND WE ARE.
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
EVERYONE EQUALLY.
THESE ARE FOLKS THAT HAVE
SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND YET TO RECEIVE THE
KIND OF MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE THAT THEY SHOULD.
RECEIVE IN AND DESERVE.
WE MUST IMPROVE AWARENESS AND
THIS IS WHY I PROUDLY WEAR THIS
TIE IS ALL OF YOU ARE WEARING
YOUR GREEN. TO BRING AWARENESS
TO GET HELP TO THOSE WHO
DEFINITELY NEED IT.
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT MUST BE A PRIORITY TO
THIS BODY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THAT ROOM WEARING YOUR GREEN AND
I SPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR SO I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THEME IS PRESENT VERY BRIEFLY IN
LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT WE HAVE.
PEACE OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS --
IN OUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY --
FOR FOR THE MEMORIALS FOR THEIR
THEIR DUTY TO THIS STATE.
I THOUGHT I'D SHARE WITH YOU ALL
A QUICK STATISTICS.
MORE MEN AND WOMEN HAVE DIED ON
THE FRONT LINES OF DUTY IN FIRST
RESPONDER WORK -- IN YEARS PAST
THAN THOSE WE LOST A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BUT IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS MORE OF DIED FROM
SUICIDE THAN IN DOING THEIR WORK
ONE IN.
FOUR POLICE OFFICERS CONTEMPLATE
SUICIDE AND ONE IN SIX
FIREFIGHTERS DO SO.
CURRENTLY THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD TO THE SENATOR FROM SAN
JOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR BILL WHICH
ELECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- ON
WEDNESDAY MAY EIGHTH.
AT EIGHT O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
WE'RE HAVING A SENATE MENTAL
HEALTH CAUCUS -- MEETING AND THE
MADDIE LOUNGE WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THAT EXACT ISSUE --
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
PRESENTATION ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND ALL MEMBERS ARE
INVITED.
ARJUN AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION OF USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF SEEING HERE NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MOVING BACK TO
PRESERVE HIS FLOOR SENATOR BILL --
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THE SPONSORS OF THE
RESOLUTION IN THE GALLERY WITH
US WE HAVE.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND FORTY WHICHI AM PROUD TO REPRESENT THE
SENATE ON CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
EACH MINE MATTERS MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA NOW MAKE
CALIFORNIA STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
ANY QUALITY CALIFORNIA ALL
GROUPS HAVE BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
OUR MAY MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
MONTH.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THEM ALL FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THIS AND
THANK ALL THE CENTERS FOR
WEARING GREEN TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL.
MISTER PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
INVITE TO CENTERS AS WE
ADJOURNED TO HAVE A PHOTOGRAPH
AFTER THE SESSION ADJOURNS THANK
YOU DO WE KNOW THINK CONSIDERED-WELL.
READ TURNING BACK TO DAILY FILE
SENATE THIRD READING NEXT ITEM
UP IS OUR ITEM TWENTY TWO
SENATOR STERN.
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN RELATIVE TO
MISKITO AWARENESS WEEK SENATOR
STERN THANK YOU IS PRESENT
MEMBERS RECENTLY ALL JOIN ME IN
PRESENTING MEMBERS RESOLUTION
MESQUITE ON VECTOR CONTROL BOARD
HERE IN HONOR OF MOSQUITO
AWARENESS WEEK.
MANY OF US INCLUDING MYSELF OF
LOS DEAR FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES
TO WHAT SEEMS LIKE.
JUST THE PAST BUT ACTUALLY CAN
TAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES THE UPTAKE
IN WEST NILE VIRUS IN THE STATE
IS VERY REAL IN WHAT YEARS LIKE
THIS ONE WE SEE THIS MORE AND
MORE IN OUR BACKYARD.
NOT JUST AGRICULTURAL AREAS.
AND SUBURBAN AND URBAN AREAS
WITH UNINTENDED SWIMMING POOLS
AND OTHER FESTERING GROUND SO
THIS A COMPANY RESOLUTION WILL
HOPEFULLY BRING MORE WHERE IT IS
TO THESE VITAL EFFORTS. TO STOP
THIS VIRUS AND BRING MORE SAFETY
TO OUR STATE WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK TRAVEL.
WE NEED.
TO DESCRIPTION OF IT ON THE SAND
DR.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND CANOGA PARK FOR
BRING THIS RESOLUTION -- FOR IN
A MOSQUITOES ARE AND FORTUNATELY
A SERIOUS FACTOR FOR DISEASE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
REMEMBER SPECIAL WE DO HAVE RAIN
HIM WE DO ENJOY WE DO NEED TO
REIN IN OUR STATE. TO BE SURE WE
DRAIN ALL STANDING WATER TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE BOTH IN OUR HOMES
AND AROUND PEOPLE AROUND OUR
NEIGHBOR'S SELF THANK YOU SO
MUCH BRING THIS RESOLUTION OR
DRIVERS.
ANY ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION
DEBATE SEEN NONE.
SINISTER WE TALKED CLOSE ON THE
SIDE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER THANK
YOU -- THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION ABUSING UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THE SIDE OF SEEING
HEARING. NINE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP ON ITEM TWENTY THREE
CENTER WORK ARE YOU READY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE BY
SENATOR WELL RELATIVE TO SOCIAL
SECURITY SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
THIS WEEK IS TEACHER
APPRECIATION WEEK.
THAT TOMORROW MAY SEVENTH IS
NATIONAL TEACHERS DAY.
SO IT'S FITTING THAT ON TODAY'S
FLOOR SESSION I AM PRESENTING
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE
WHICH URGES CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO REPEL TO FEDERAL
POLICIES THAT HAVE FOR YEARS
BEEN DESTRUCTIVE TO THE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
OF OUR TEACHERS AND MANY OTHER
PUBLIC SERVANTS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CONVENTION OFFSET
ALSO KNOWN AS GPO AND THE
WINDFALL ELIMINATION PROVISION
KNOWN AS WELL.
WERE INTRODUCED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AS A WAY TO PREVENT
DOUBLE DIPPING FROM GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE GPO AND WEB
MANY PUBLIC SERVICE MAY SEE
THEIR BENEFITS CLASS IF THEY OR
THEIR SPOUSE HAPPEN TO HAVE BEEN
HAPPEN TO HAVE PAID INTO SOCIAL
SECURITY.
AS WELL AS A SEPARATE GOVERNMENT
PENSION.
THESE INDIVIDUALS MAY SEE THEIR
RIGHTFULLY EARNED SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS SLASH OR
ELIMINATED DUE TO THESE LAWS.
THE GPL WEBER ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMFUL TO
WOMEN WHO MAKE UP 7372% OF
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND THEY
USUALLY DON'T FIND OUT ABOUT THE
PENALTY UNTIL AFTER THEY RETIRE.
THESE PENALTIES CAN ALSO
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM PURSUING
VALUABLE GOVERNMENT CAREERS.
THIS MEANS OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ANOTHER PART PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
LOSING OUT A MUCH NEEDED TALENT.
THE GPO AND WET MAY HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
GOVERNMENT BUT INSTEAD.
THEY HAVE RESULTED IN THE
GOVERNMENT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE PEOPLE AS WELL PAST TIME TO
REPEL THE G. -- GPO AND WEBER
AND ESPECIALLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ON SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
THREE ANY ADDITIONAL --
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
JUNE TWO NINE MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
WELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ART I HAVE A ADAM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS IN.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROVE [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG. FIVE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE
[inaudible]
HI AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WELL
[inaudible]
HI.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR
GLAZER ARE YOU READY FOR THIS
ITEM.
PASS ON FILE.
NEXT ITEM TWENTY FIVE SENATORS
SKINNER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS INNER SKINNER WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB.
TWO NINETY THREE WOULD ALLOW THE
CITY OF OAKLAND TO FORM.
AN INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICT. TO HELP SUPPORT THE
FINANCING OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED FOR PROPOSED STADIUM
PROJECT.
V..
ANY FINANCING THAT EMANATES FROM
THE DISTRICT WOULD NOT BE USED
FOR THE ACTUAL STADIUM ITSELF.
THAT IS GOING TO BE PRIVATELY
FINANCED BUT RATHER FOR THE
OTHER TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE THE MAY BE NEEDED
AT THE SITE WHICH IS THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SOME DISTANCE FROM THE
PORT OF OAKLAND -- SO IT ALLOWS
THE CITY TO DO SO.
CHANCE THE TERM FOR THE TAX
INCREMENTS TO FORTY FIVE YEARS
OUR CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT.
TIME PERIOD IS THIRTY YEARS THIS
WOULD ALLOW IT TO GO FOR FORTY
FIVE YEARS -- STAND IT.
ALLOWS FOR A PROTEST PROCESS
RATHER THAN THE VOTER APPROVAL
THAT'S REQUIRED FOR OTHER
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
AND PART OF THE MOTIVATION IS
THAT IS THAT THIS IS AN AREA
THAT HAS VERY FEW RESIDENTS --
FIVE AGREED TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR BIG
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION IN OUR STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
PART THERE ARE AUTHORITY IN THIS
MATTER OR NOT SUPERSEDED.
BUT WE WERE UNABLE TO TAKE THOSE
BEFORE IT WENT TO THE FLOOR BUT
WE WILL BE SO WE WILL BE
ENSURING THAT BOTH STATE LANDS
AND BE CDC WHICH HAVE AUTHORITY --
BECAUSE THIS IS ADJACENT TO THE
BAY THAT THEIR AUTHORITY IS
COMPLETELY RESPECTED WITHIN THIS
BILL.
AND WITHOUT AYE ASPIRO VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF SENATOR
MORAL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
I'VE STAYING ON THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE AND BEEN TRYING TO DO
A LOT OF THINKING ABOUT IT I GIL
NERVOUS ABOUT CERTAIN
TRANSACTIONS AND LOOK FOR THE
CLOSELY AT THE CITY OF OAKLAND --
WE REVIEWED ALL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IT'S DISTRICT IS --
SIX EIGHTY TWO OUT OF NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR AND BASED
ON ITS SIZE OF ITS UNRESTRICTED
NET POSITION IT PLACE NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY WITH. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT -- IN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE DID A STUDY OF ALL
THE CITIES. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO OF THEM IN OAKLAND CAME IN
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINTH
PLACE JUST ABOUT DEAD LAST.
AND WE USE THEIR JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY SIXTEEN KAFFIR BECAUSE IT
WASN'T -- WE DON'T HAVE THE
SEVENTEEN KAFFIR BUT IT HAD A
ONE POINT SEVEN NINE BILLION
DOLLARS.
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT WE JUST
RECENTLY GOT THE SEVENTEEN AUDIT
IT'S A ONE POINT EIGHT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT AND THE
JUNE THIRTY EIGHTEEN KAFFIR CAME
OUT AND IT'S UP TO TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
THANKS.
TO OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
SO LEAST TO GET THEIR FINANCIALS
OUT THE CALIFORNIA TODAY IS
MAYES SIX WE STILL HAVEN'T
RECEIVED OURS.
BUT THIS LITTLE COMMUNITY ONLY
HAS [inaudible]
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
RESIDENTS SO.
I'M GONNA VOTE.
FOR SB TWO NINETY THREE MISTER
PRESIDENT BUT I'M DOING IT WITH
SOME.
CONCERN ON ALLOWING THE CREATION
OF AN INDEPENDENT INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT.
WHICH IS SORT OF REDEVELOPMENT
LIKE VEHICLE -- AND I'M WILL
CONCERN THAT EXCLUDES VOTER
INVOLVEMENT ON DEBT ISSUANCE.
BUT WE'VE SEEN SOME.
SUCCESSFUL [inaudible]
BASEBALL STADIUMS -- IN THE PAST
I WAS THERE FOR THE FIRST YEAR
OF COURSE FIELD IN DENVER AND IT
WAS FULL -- PETCO IS DOING WELL
IN SAN DIEGO BUT OAKLAND NEEDS A
A SHOT IN THE ARM.
AND IT NEEDS AN ECONOMIC BOOST
TO IMPROVE ITS ITS ITS.
DISTRESSFUL A BALANCE SHEET I'M
NOT SURE MOVING A BASEBALL
STADIUM WILL DO THE TRICK BUT I
SURE HOPE IT DOES.
BUT IF IT DOESN'T I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE FOR ENCOURAGING AN AYE
VOTE ON SB.
TWO NINE THREE ANY ADDITION IS
KOSHER DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HERE IN CHINO AND CENTER SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I'M YES THANK YOU -- ARE JUST A
LITTLE REMINDER THAT OUR AND I'M
NOT INDICATING THAT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER IMPLIED THIS BUT OUR
LEGISLATION REGARDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS.
DOES NOT TAKE ANY PROPERTY TAX
INCREMENTS THAT WOULD GO TO OUR
SCHOOLS -- SO IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN REDEVELOPMENT IN THAT
REGARD.
SO -- BEYOND THE ENTITIES THAT
WOULD BE INVOLVED WHO'S OUT
PROPERTY MIGHT PARTICIPATE IN IT
MUST ELECT TO PARTICIPATE.
SO WITH THAT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE WELL.
I FORGES.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
FIVE JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I MORE LOG [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible] FIVE RUBIO
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI HI.
CENTER SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP MEMBERS ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD ART IS
HE'S NOT AT HIS DESK TO J.
MOVING ON NEXT UP ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT BY CENTER HERTZBERG.
NURSE FOR YOU PREPARED.
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT.
SENATORS BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ONE
OF OUR JOBS HERE IN GOVERNMENT
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
PLAYS BY THE SAME RULES.
WITH REGARD TO ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY THAT JOB IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO ME.
BECAUSE SO MANY IN THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WERE FILM
TELEVISION OTHER ENTERTAINMENT
FIELDS -- HAVE GROWN AND
DEVELOPED GIVING CALIFORNIA'S
TRIBUTE TATIAN AS A CENTER OF IN
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
THIS MEASURE SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
MIR'S THE EXCEPTION FOR MOTION
PICTURE EMPLOYEES SET FORTH IN
LABOR CODE SECTION TWO OR ONE
POINT.
FIVE AND ALLOWS PRINT SHOOT
EMPLOYEES WAGES TO BE PAID ON
THE NEXT REGULAR PAYDAY AS
OTHERS IN THE INDUSTRY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG ANY
ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEE NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS -- IT.
NO I'M SORRY CALDERON SHARK
CALLED WERE.
CALDERON MA'AM SECTOR
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL. FIVE FOR JUST
[inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEIR OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I HER DAUGHTER [inaudible] FIVE
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING [inaudible]
I WARLOCK [inaudible] FIVE
ROUNDS [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
HI.
SOONER HERTZBERG MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM TWENTY NINE SOONER
HILL YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM YES SIR MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR.
AN ACT RELATING TO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB THIRTY NINE WILL
IMPOSE STRICT.
STRICTER AGE VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SOLD ONLINE OR BY EMAIL
OR BY MAIL SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT YOUTH HAVE EASY
ACCESS TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS
ONLINE ONE STUDY EVEN FOUND THAT
MINERS WERE SUCCESSFUL.
IN BUYING E. CIGARETTES ONLINE
93% OF THE TIME AND 95% OF THE
CIGARETTE DELIVERIES WERE SIMPLY
LEFT AT THE DOOR.
MODEL AFTER STANDARDS FOR
ALCOHOL DELIVERY SB THIRTY NINE
WILL REQUIRE TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO
BE DELIVERED ONLY IN CONTAINERS
LABELED WITH THE WORDS QUOTE.
CONTAINS TOBACCO PRODUCTS
SIGNATURE OF PERSON TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER REQUIRED
FOR DELIVERY.
THE BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE
TOBACCO VENDORS TO OBTAIN THE
SIGNATURE OF A PERSON TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER BEFORE
DELIVERY IN A TOBACCO PRODUCT SB
THIRTY NINE ESTABLISHES A
BASELINE PROTECTIONS.
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE FOR
ALCOHOL AND OTHER PRODUCTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
MEMBERS.
IN ADDITION TO JUST PETER --
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING TO NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVEA A I
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS IN [inaudible] FIVE
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWS [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TOTEM [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING [inaudible]
I WARLOCK [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible] FIVE STERN
[inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
THE SERIAL MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM THIRTY SENATOR
BATES BE PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR BATES AN ACT RELATING TO
PEARL SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SENATE BILL ONE FORTY
ONE ENSURES THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES BY REQUIRING THAT
ALL INMATES CONVICTED OF A
SEXUALLY.
VIOLENT OFFENSE BE ADMINISTERED
A RISK ASSESSMENT BEFORE RELEASE
CURRENTLY BEFORE THEY ARE
RELEASED FROM PRISON INMATES
SENTENCED TO A DETERMINATE TERM.
FOR SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSE ARE
EVALUATED FOR POTENTIAL MENTAL
DISORDERS AFTER TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE SB ONE FORTY ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT A SIMILAR EVALUATION
IS THAT MINISTERED. TO INMATES
SENTENCED TO AN INDETERMINATE OR
LIFE SENTENCE FOR SEXUALLY
VIOLENT CRIMES WHO BEING BEEN
MADE ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE.
THIS PROCESS WILL GUARANTEE THAT
INMATES WHO HAVE A PRIOR
SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSE OR A
SENSE DURING THE PAROLE BOARD
HEARING.
PROCESS FOR THEIR POTENTIAL RISK
TO RE OF FAN IT DOES NOT ARE
CREATING NEW DUPLICATIVE PROCESS
OUTSIDE OF AN INMATE'S PAROLE
BOARD HEARING.
BUT IN A GRAYSON NECESSARY
SAFEGUARD INTO THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
YOU NEED TO FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I TELL.
HI FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ITEM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI DRAWS -- HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I REQUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I BROWN.
HI NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible] FIVE SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR BABES MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM.
THIRTY SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
TWO BY SENATOR HELMS AN ACT
RELATING TO DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU BACK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SB TWO TWENTY TWO IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN FROM LAST YEAR.
WHICH WAS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WITH BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SB TWO TWENTY TWO WOULD WERE
PROTECTED VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
AND ENSURE THAT LANDLORDS CANNOT
DENY HOMELESS VETERANS HOUSING
BASED SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT
THEY RECEIVE A RENTAL HOUSING
VOUCHER.
US VETERANS AND THOSE CURRENTLY
SERVING IN THE ARMED FORCES ARE
PROTECTED FROM EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
HOWEVER THE LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE VETERANS OR
MILITARY PERSONNEL AMONG THOSE
WHO ARE PROTECTED FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
ALMOST EVERY OTHER PROTECTED
CLASS IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT IS PROTECTED IN BOTH
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION STATUTES AS BE.
TWENTY TWENTY THE TWO TWENTY TWO
WOULD ADDRESS THIS GAP BY ADDING
VETERANS AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
AS A PROTECTED CLASS IN STATUTES
RELATING TO HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION THE BILL WILL
ALSO ENSURE OUR HEROES ARE NOT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN HOUSING.
AND ARE NOT DENIED HOUSING
BECAUSE OF HOW THEY PAY THEIR
RENT OR VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL ALREADY FACE
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CHALLENGES
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY.
ABOUT BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST WHEN TRYING TO FIND A
HOME FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE RESPECT FOR YES FOR
AYE VOTE COLLEGE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON HEARING
SEEN NINE MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I BORDERS.
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT HI COME BY
OTHER.
I CHIANG.
I DON.
I DRAWS THEM.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I HEARD -- TADA [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I AM MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LAW [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
HI RALPH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M. FIVE WHAT KASKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR HILL MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
LABOR YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
PASS ON FILE MIX UPS.
ITEM THIRTY THREE CENTS SENATOR
SKINNER.
SHE LOOKS PREPARED AMOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO FAMILY DAY CARE HOMES.
CENTERS SKINNER WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IT SHOULD SURPRISE NO.
ONE THAT AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE
IS IN SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA --
FAMILY DAY CARE CENTERS MEANING
I HILD CARE OFFERED IN A HOME.
IS A VERY ACCESSIBLE.
AND AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR
CHILDCARE AND WHAT SB TWO THIRTY
FOUR DOES.
IS HELP FACILITATE OUR FAMILY
HOME CHILDCARE PROGRAMS.
BY ALLOWING.
THERE THE PERMIT PROCESS FOR
THESE PROGRAMS TO BE TREATED THE
SAME FOR A SMALL OR LARGE AND OF
COURSE LARGE IS STILL A VERY
LIMITED NUMBER BUT FOR THESE
TYPE OF HOMES.
IT ALSO ENSURES THAT CHILD CARE
pIS ALLOWED IN APARTMENTS AND
CONDOS WHICH IS ALREADY EXISTS
IN THE LAW BUT THERE'S BEEN SOME
AMBIGUITY.
AND IT ASKS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO INFORM THE
FAMILY DAYCARE PROVIDERS OF
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
AND SB TWO THIRTY FOUR AS NO
OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT I ASKED
ZERO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BORCHERS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT IS WANTED -- TO
COMMEND -- OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BERKELEY -- ON THIS WE THINK WE
ALL KNOW HOW DESPERATELY -- WE
NEED -- DAYCARE AN IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES OF THAT KIND --
SO GLAD TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE WELL.
I BRIDGES.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVE A A I
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS IN.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL. FIVE HUESO.
HI -- TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LONG [inaudible]
I ROW.
HI NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I'VE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SKINNER SKINNER MOVES A CALL.
PICKS UP ITEM THIRTY FOUR SOONER
CHIANG OR YOU.
PASS ON FILE.
NEXT.
ITEM THIRTY FIVES DARK SOONER
PAN.
HAS BEEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST ACROSS
THE STATE RESULTING IN A BACKLOG
OF LABORATORY WORK.
SB THREE THIRTY FOR THE DRESS
THE SHORTAGE BY ESTABLISHING A
MEDICAL LAB TECH TO CLINICAL LAB
SCIENTIST CAREER PATHWAY.
THE PATHWAY WOULD CREATE AN
EXPEDITED PROCESS FOR A MEDICAL
LAB TECH TO T. LICENSURE AS A
CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST BY
ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ELIMINATE
REDUNDANCIES IN THE TRAINING
BETWEEN THE TWO PROGRAMS.
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS WOULD NOT
CHANGE SB THREE THIRTY FOR THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BILL WHICH
WOULD ENCOURAGE MEDICAL LAB
TECHNICIANS TO SEEK HIGHER
SKILLED WORK OPPORTUNITIES.
AS CLINICAL LAB SCIENTIST
THEREBY REDUCING LEVITRA
BACKLOGS ACROSS THE STATE I
SUSPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEN IN HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO. FIVE CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROSS [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I REQUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MOREAU [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I'VE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE HE I WIENER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
DOCTRINE MOVES CALL.
EXCEPT ARE SOONER WHICH SHOW ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR ITEM.
THIRTY THIRTY SIX MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES [inaudible]
DINNER HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE HERE IN THE
SENATE FLOOR PRESENT SB. THREE
SIX SEVEN IT'S A MEASURE THAT.
ENHANCES THE STATE CONE SO
COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S AUTHORITY
TO PROVIDE GRANTS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROTECTING STATES
COASTAL RESOURCES AND IMPROVING.
PUBLIC ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE
TO THOSE RESOURCES.
THE STAKE ALSO CONSERVANCY.
IS A NON REGULATORY AGENCY THAT
SEEKS TO INCREASE COASTAL ACCESS
THROUGH THE ACQUISITION OF LAND
AND THROUGH GRANT PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT.
TRIBES NONPROFITS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES EFFORT TO INCREASE
COASTAL ACCESS TO RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT BENEFIT
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
CALIFORNIA'S COAST BELONGS.
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS NO MATTER
WHERE THEY LIVE SB THREE SIX
SEVEN WILL BUILD ON THE
CONSERVANCY'S.
EFFORT TO INCREASE COASTAL
ACCESS BY ALLYING GRANTS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION ARE IMPROVEMENT.
OF ON SITE AND DISTANCE LEARNING
FACILITIES I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- WHEN THIS BILL IS A
NATURIST SOURCES COMMITTEE I
ABSTAINED?
AND ASKED THAT IS THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD THAT'D BE AMENDED SO THE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS REMAIN
CONSISTENT.
WITH THE STATE EDUCATION BOARDS
STANDARDS THE AUTHOR GRACIOUSLY
MADE THOSE AMENDMENT SO I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION DISCUSSION
OF A SCENE HEARING ON CENTER WAY
SO YOU MAY CLOSE -- SIMPLY -- IT
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR HIS SUPPORT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK.
FOR ALL THE SENATOR SUPPORT HERE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
I FELL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS IN.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
I GROW.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
HI WHAT KASKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
THERE WAS SOME OF THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM THIRTY SEVEN BY
CENTER ON BURGER SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY CENTER
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES AS YOU ALL KNOW
HOMELESSNESS.
IS AN ISSUE THAT AFFECTS ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES STAYING IN MOTELS.
BUT JUST FOR A WEEKEN OR A
COUPLE OF DAYS BUT ACTUALLY
LIVING THERE FOR WEEKS MONTHS AT
A TIME.
IN ADDITION MANY OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE TOLD US THAT.
THESE MOTELS ARE A MAJOR
NUISANCE THEY HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
POLICE CALLS IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES TAKING PLACE.
THIS BILL IS BEFORE FIFTY WILL
ALL CITY GOVERNMENTS.
ARE SERVICE PROVIDERS APP TO
PURCHASE THESE MOTELS WITH
PURPOSE CONVERTING THESE MOTELS
INTO TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
BY PASSING THE SEQUEL PROCESS TO
BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
NEW BUILDINGS MAJOR REMODELING
OR ANYTHING THAT WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY CALLS OUT
ONLY MINOR INTERIOR ALTERATIONS
TO ADD COOKING FACILITIES
CLOONEY IS SINKING REFRIGERATOR
COUNTER SPACE NOT EXCEEDING TEN
SQUARE FEET.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLE OUR
COMMUNITIES THE THIS
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. TO THE
ABLE TO PROVIDE A TRANSITIONAL.
PLACE FOR THE HOMELESS BILL TO
SECURE A STABLE LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES BILLS ENDORSED.
BY THIRTEEN BIG CITY MAYORS.
AND A NUMBER OF RURAL COUNTIES
THE TOOL WE CAN ALL USE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I FELL.
HI FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVE A I DON'T.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I DRAWS IN.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE E. [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MOVE THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO YOU'RE PREPARED
FOR THIS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
SENATOR RUBIO.
MISTER PRESIDENT A MEMBERS TEARS
DOWN 2% SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
THIS BILL UPDATES THE MEMBERSHIP
MAKE UP OF THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING BY
REPLACING ONE MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC.
WITH A CERTIFIED HUMAN RESOURCE
ADMINISTRATOR THE CDC OVERSEES
ALL ASPECTS OF THE SERVICE.
VACATION PROCESS WITH THE
COMPLEXITY OF CREDENTIALING
ASSIGNMENTS COMBINED WITH
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS THIS MINOR
CHANGE TO THE CDC.
SHOULD BE MADE TO REFLECT THE
CHALLENGES AND NEEDS OF THE
SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL PASSED AT THE SENATE
EDUCATION WITH STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KNOW I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITION
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF
KERN SEEN ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELT.
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD.
AYE CANNELLA.
I CHIANG.
I DONT.
I DRAWS -- AYE GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADA.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I HAVE LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL.
I MONNING.
AYE WARLOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI RALPH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
IN A RUBIO MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM THIRTY NOW LINED
BY SENATOR JONES HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING
TO TIME SHARES COMMITTEES FLOORS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
UPDATES THE LAWS GOVERNING TIME
SHARES.
REGARDING A LODGING REQUIREMENTS
IN ARBITRATION I HUMBLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
XENON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE AM SIR
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I WELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ART I HAVE A ITEM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DON [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I'D CALL JOHNNY [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I SADDAM [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM.
NIELSEN.
AYE PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
I STONE.
HI NUMBER.
I LIKE HOW SKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SOONER JONES MOVES A CALL.
MIX UP ITEM FORTY SENATOR BATES
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BATES AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALING ARTS.
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB SIX SEVENTY NINE
SEEKS TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE HELD A
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER OR
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
LICENSE FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS
IN ANOTHER STATE. TO BECOME
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
CURRENT LAW THESE LICENSEES AND
OTHER STATES MUST MEET ALL
EDUCATION AND SUPERVISED
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT A BRAND NEW APPLICANTS MUST
MEET WHEN THEY COME TO
CALIFORNIA EVEN IF THEY HAVE
BEEN LICENSE FOR MANY YEARS OR
DECADES IN THEIR HOME STATE.
THIS NEW PROPOSAL WOULD HONOR
THE EXPERIENCE THEY HAVE IS A
LICENSEE AND THEIR HOME STATE
WHILE STILL MAKING SURE THEY
OBTAIN ADDITIONAL CASE WORK
FORCE WERE. TO TEACH THEM
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC LAWS AND
HELP THEM PRACTICE OF THE
ACTIVELY AND CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE ENVIRONMENT THE PROPOSAL
IS CONSISTENT WITH THEIR FIRST
SET A NATIONAL LEVEL. TO IMPROVE
LICENSE PORTABILITY ACROSS
STATES AND ALSO IS IN LINE WITH
THREE RECENT RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S WILL HOOVER
COMMISSION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HERE IN SPAIN NINE MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ALRIGHT I COMPARE
[inaudible] FIVE CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DON.
HI DRAWS -- I GALGIANI. FIVE
GLAZER.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SENT [inaudible]
HI TARA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE.
HI I'M BURKE. FIVE WHAT CASTING.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SOONER BATES MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR
STERN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS.
DINNER STERN FAMOUS PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS LAST YEAR WE WE PASS SB
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE WHICH ALLOWED.
BALLOT INITIATIVES TO BE REMOVED
AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME
AT THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I TO ALLOW.
MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR NEGOTIATION --
AND LESS FORCED CROWDED BALLOTS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS WORK WOULD
HAVE ALLOWED WEEK WEEKLY TO
CHARTER CITIES FROM THE
AUTHORITY TO REMOVE UNNECESSARY
OR CUMBERSOME MEASURES FROM
THEIR BALLOTS SB SIX ANYONE
WOULD ALLOW PROPONENTS WITHDRAW
REFERENDA AS WELL -- THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO WITHDRAW THEIR
MEASURES AT ANY TIME PRIOR TO
THE EIGHTY DAY BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
WHETHER OR NOT THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO DETERMINE IF THEY
HAVE SUFFICIENT VALID SIGNATURES
TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT
ADDITIONALLY SB SIX ANYONE
EXTENDS THE AUTHORITY. TO
WITHDRAW THE CHARTER CITIES
ALLOWING THEM TO REMOVE MEASURES
AS WELL -- AT LAST YEAR'S BE
ELEVEN FIFTY THREE WAS CHAPTER --
BUT DID NOT INCLUDE EITHER OF
THESE AUTHORITIES THIS BILL IS
NO OPPOSITION -- SUPPORTED BY
THE CITY'S WOMEN VOTERS CITY
SACRAMENTO CA I USE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM HERE IN CHINO AND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI I KAMALA.
I CHANGE.
I DON.
I DRAWS IN [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I TELL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I SADDAM [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I BROWN.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I MY CASTING. FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER STERN MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM FORTY TWO SENATOR
RUBIO OR YOU PREPARE PASS ON
FILE NEXT UP ITEM FORTY THREE
SENATOR ARCHULETA ARE YOU
PREPARED.
YES SHE IS MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
SOONER OUR GELATO THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I TODAY I
PRESENT -- SB FIVE FIVE TWO
WHICH WILL DELETE THE SUNSET ON
APPROVING CURBSIDE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE COLLECTION
PROGRAM AND ENCOURAGE THE USE OF
DOOR TO DOOR HOUSEHOLD.
HAZARDOUS WASTE COLLECTION.
MANY OF THE PRODUCTS COMMONLY
USED IN AROUND HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
TOXIC PROPERTIES IF IT FROM
PROPERLY DISPOSED CAN HARM HUMAN.
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB FOUR FIVE
SIX BY SENATOR HUFF.
WHICH ALLOWED HAZARDS WAGE
TRANSPORTED TO PICK UP HOW TO
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND HAVE IT TAKEN TO MULTIPLE
TYPES OF PERMITTED FACILITIES.
TO DISPOSE UP AND STORED AND
RECYCLED.
CURRENTLY HAS RIDGEWAY
TRANSPORTERS ARE ALLOWED TO PICK
UP AND TRACK HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE BY UTILIZING UNIFORM
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
MANIFESTS BY ALLOWING THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE TRANSPORTED TO
KEEP CONSOLIDATED BENEFITS
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
HOUSEHOLD PICK UP SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIANS AND ENSURE THAT
HOUSEHOLD.
HAZARDOUS WASTE GETS PROPERLY
DISPOSED UP IN THE ROOM AND
REMAIN OUT OF THE MAINSTREAM.
THIS BROUGHT THIS PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN TO WORK IN MANY CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL SB FIVE
FIVE TWO WILL ENSURE.
THAT THESE PROGRAMS CONTINUE
INDEFINITELY INTO THE FUTURE
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITION
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING NONE MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ART I KAMALA.
I CHIANG.
HI DON [inaudible]
DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
I CAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I'VE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I NUMBER.
HI MY CASTING [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SOONER ARCHULETA MOVED TO CALL.
NEXT UP ITEM FORTY FOUR SENATOR
JONES HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING TO
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS.
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT A SPLIT DOLLAR LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY ALLOWS THE COST
AND BENEFIT OF A PERMANENT LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY TO BE SHARED.
CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY ALLOWS
NONPROFITS TO OFFER THESE UNIQUE
POLICIES TO THEIR OFFICERS.
AS AN EMPLOYMENT BENEFIT THAT
ENDS UP BEING COST TO NEUTRAL TO
THE NONPROFIT.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY SLIGHTLY
ADJUST THE VALUE THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE HELD A SECURITY
ON A SPLIT DOLLAR LIFE INSURANCE
POLICY UNDER LOAN REGIME. TO THE
DEATH BENEFIT OR THE CASH
SURRENDER VALUE OR BOTH.
THIS SMALL CHANGE SERVES AS A
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION TOOL
FOR NON PROFITS.
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE OFFICER TO
UTILIZE SOME OF THE CASH VALUE
OF THE POLICY WHILE ENSURING
THERE IS ENOUGH VALUE LEFT TO
REPAIR THE NONPROFIT FOR ANY
COSTS INCURRED.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
PRESIDENT ON AS I SHARED WITH
MISTER JONES AND COMMITTEE I
LAID OFF IN COMMITTEE AND I'LL
BE VOTING NO TODAY -- I
APPRECIATED THE BALL THE BILL
WAS AMENDED IN BANKING BUT IT.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO GET TO THE
CORE ISSUE THAT I HAD A CONCERN
WITH.
EXECUTIVE COMPENSATION IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS -- MONITORED
RATHER CLOSELY IT FILED ON THE
NONPROFIT TO NINE NINETY
STATEMENT.
I APPRECIATE OF THE THE AUTHOR
FEELS THAT -- SOME OF THE HIGHLY
COMPENSATED EMPLOYEES ABOUT THE
LARGER NONPROFITS LIKE HOSPITALS
ARE UNIVERSITIES HAVE DIFFICULTY
RECRUITING THAT THAT'S NOT MY
EXPERIENCE NOR IS IT THE HOLES.
IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
ASSOCIATION THE CONCERN WITH THE
BILL IS IT APPEARS TO WEEK IN
LOSS AGAINST SELF DEALING.
AGAIN IN ORDER PROVIDE A SMALL
NUMBER OF NONPROFITS ABILITY TO
PAY HIGHLY COMPENSATED EMPLOYEES
MORE WITHOUT VIOLATING OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON HIGH
COMPENSATION AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
NECESSARY TOOL TO ALLOW
NONPROFITS TO RECRUIT HIGHLY
HIGHLY COMPENSATED INDIVIDUALS
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING SB FIVE FORTY TODAY.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION
DESCRIPTION IS VERY.
XENON SOONER JONES WERE TO LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT -- THIS TOOL IS USED
BY A LOT OF NON PROFITS IT'S
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR THEM FOR
RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
HI BATES RIGHT I FELT
[inaudible]
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A I DON'T.
I CHIANG.
I DONE.
I DRAWS A NO CHARGE ANI.
GLAZER.
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
HI JACKSON.
JONES HI I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
NO MONEY.
MORE LOCK.
I ROOM.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
NO STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible] FIVE NUMBER.
I LIKE CASTING [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
HI HI KING'S INNER JONES WAS A
CALL.
NEXT UP ON FORTY FIVE SOONER
HERTZBERG WHERE.
SHE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY THREE BY
pSENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL FACILITIES
CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MEMBERS OFTEN
USE A DESIGN BUILD PROJECT
DELIVERY METHOD IN SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION TO ACHIEVE BOTH OF
THE PROJECT GOALS AS WELL AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
ON THE ONE HAND WE HAVE THIS
MEMBERS WERE INVOLVED IN THE
SNOW THAT WE HAVE DESIGNED BILL
THE NEXT BUT I DELIVERY OF A
PROJECT.
THAT ALLOWS FOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- TO AWARD CONTRACTS
TO DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTOR THAT
ALLOWS THAT PROJECT TO BEGIN ON
THE OTHER HAND THE CALIFORNIA
BAR MIDDLE QUALITY ACT REQUIRES
FULL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REVIEW.
TO BE COMPLETED BEFORE THE
PROJECT THIS BILL HARMONIZES THE
SEQUEL AND DESIGN BUILD MEASURES
TO WARD ACCUSE ME TO CLARIFY
THAT THE AWARDING OF THE
CONTRACT DOES NOT MEAN APPROVAL
IN OTHER WORDS WE'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE'S BEEN AN
AWARDING BUT THE SEQUEL PROCESS
HAS NOT BEEN COMPLETED.
THIS MAKE SURE THAT AWARDING
CONSTANT IT DOES NOT A COST TO
THAT IT IS SPONSORED BY BOTH THE
LA U. S. D. AND THE BUILDING
TRADES OF CALIFORNIA I ASK
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION OF A SCENE HEARING
NINE MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS -- I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I DATA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
I MONEY.
I MORE LOOK [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE.
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHAT CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
THE SOONER HERTZBERG MOVES CALL.
PICKS UP ITEM FORTY SIX SOONER
GLAZER YOU PREPARED FOR THE SIDE.
HE IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
SENATOR GLAZER RELATIVE TO THE
MERRILL'S MARAUDERS
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL ACT.
CENTERED LARGER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- S. T. R.
SEVEN IS A RESOLUTION THAT URGES
CONGRESS TO HONOR MERRILL'S
MARAUDERS WITH THE CONGRESSIONAL
GOLD MEDAL.
MERRILL'S MARAUDERS THREE UNITED
STATES ARMY SPECIAL OPERATIONS
UNIT WHICH BECAME FAMOUS FOR ITS
DANGEROUS MISSIONS BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
IN THE JUNGLES OF BURMA. ONE OF
THE MAJOR STAGING GROUNDS FOR
THIS MISSION -- WAS IN
PITTSBURGH IN MY DISTRICT FROM
CAMP STONEMAN.
RECENTLY ONE OF THIS LAST
SURVIVORS PLACED A WREATH AT
CAMP STONEMAN FROM MORRELL.
AT THE PITTSBURGH HISTORICAL
MUSEUM TO COMMEMORATE THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THAT NINETEEN FORTY FOUR MERRITT
MERRILL'S MARAUDERS MISSION
THAT'S HONOR THESE MEN AND ASK
CONGRESS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
TERRORISM.
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD ART I HAVE A A I
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DONT.
I DRAWS THEM [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible] FIVE GLAZER
[inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible] FIVE LEYVA
[inaudible]
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I REVIEW [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE
[inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
GLAZER MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT CENTER STERN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS I DON'T.
PASS ON FILE NEXT UP ITEM FORTY
NINE WELLS SENATOR WHITE KASKI
DISAPPEAR [inaudible]
J..
MOVING ON TO ITEM FIFTY SENATOR
HILL.
BASS ON FILE.
NEXT UP FIFTY ONE SOONER JONES
SHE'S READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ME PLEASE READ I'M SORRY.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR JONES AN ACT RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT LAND SURVEYORS REPORT
THAT THEY ARE INCREASINGLY ASKED
TO ENTER INTO NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
THAT SEE SEEK TO PROHIBIT ANY
REPORTING VIOLATIONS OF
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS. TO THE
REGULATORY BOARD SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY NINE ENHANCES
CONSUMER PROTECTION BY
CLARIFYING THAT WHEN A LAND
SURVEYOR IS RETAINED.
AS AN EXPERT IN SEVILLE CIVIL
PROCEEDINGS ANY NDA SIGNED BY
THE SURVEYOR MAY NOT PROHIBIT
THE SURVEYOR FROM REPORTING
MALPRACTICE. FOR THE REGULATORY
AGENCY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHIE LETTER.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I KAMALA
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I ASSUME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
I JONES. FIVE LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR JONES MOVES TO CALL.
NEXT UP IS ITEM.
FIFTY THREE SENATOR COVER YOUR
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THE SONYA
SHE IS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR CUT BY A RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL NURSES WEEK.
CENTER FOR YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS 2% SR
THIRTY FOUR WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
WEEK OF MAY SIXTH AS NATIONAL
NURSES WEEK.
EVERYONE OF US HAS BEEN CARED
FOR AT SOME POINT IN OUR LIVES
BY A NURSE.
AT BIRTH OR THROUGH ILLNESS
NURSES ARE THE CARETAKERS WE ALL
DEPEND ON IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STAGES.
I KNOW WE ALL LOVE AND VENERATE
OUR MOTHERS BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE SKILL AND
DEDICATION OF MY MOTHER WHO IS A
REGISTERED NURSE.
SHE NOT ONLY TOOK CARE OF US
KIDS WE WERE SICK BUT SHE WAS A
GO TO PERSON IN A VERY LARGE
EXTENDED FAMILY.
WHENEVER ANYONE WAS ILL OR NOT
FEELING WELL OR WAS GIVEN A
DIFFICULT DIAGNOSIS MY MOTHER AS
A REGISTERED NURSE WAS AVAILABLE
TO GIVE ADVICE AND HELP IN ANY
WAY POSSIBLE.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND ACTIVELY LICENSED
REGISTERED NURSES MAKING NURSING
THE SINGLE LARGEST HEALTH
PROFESSION IN THE STATE.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S OUR END
WORKFORCE REMAINSPREDOMINANTLY
FEMALE IN RECENT YEARS MORE MEN
HAVE ENTERED THE WORKFORCE.
IN FACT THE SHARE OF MEN WORKING
IN NURSING IN CALIFORNIA MORE
THAN DOUBLED BETWEEN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHICH IS FIFTEEN YEARS.
CALIFORNIA'S ARE AND WORKFORCE
BECAME INCREASINGLY RACIALLY AND
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE OVER THE PAST
TWO DECADES AS WELL.
NURSES OF COLOR GROUP FROM 23%
2401% OF THE ARE IN WORKFORCE
SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY IN NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR THE FIRST EVER
NATIONAL NURSES WEEK WAS
OBSERVED ON OCTOBER ELEVENTH.
HONORING THEIR ONE HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY OF FLORENCE
NIGHTINGALE'S WORKING CREMIA.
THEN IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
BOARD OF DIRECTORS DESIGNATED
THE DATES OF MAY SIXTH THROUGH
THE TWELVE AS PERMANENT DAYS TO
OBSERVE NATIONAL NURSES WEEK.
LET US TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
AND APPRECIATE ALL OF THE NURSES
THAT WE KNOW OR WHO HAVE BEEN
THERE WHEN WE NEEDED THAT THEIR
HELP THE MOST.
THEIR WORK IS CRITICAL TO OUR
WELL BEING AND DESERVE
RECOGNITION AND RESPECT PLEASE
JOIN ME TODAY IN RECOGNIZING
NATIONAL NURSES WEEK WHICH
ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIA DO HONOR
THE WORK OF OUR OF OUR CARE AND
WELLNESS GIVERS IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SHEENA AND MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVE A I DON'T
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible] FIVE DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
JEFF I JONES.
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LAW [inaudible]
I ROOM.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL [inaudible]
FOR GROW BY.
NEXT UP ITEM FIFTY FOUR SENATOR
ARGILLITE ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THIS ITEM.
THIS YEAR'S MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE.
THREE SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY
FIVE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO TARDIVE DYSKINESIA
AWARENESS WEEK [inaudible]
CENTER ARTILLERY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO BRING A
FOURTH SR.
THIRTY FIVE RECOGNIZING THE
FIRST FULL WEEK OF MAY AS PART
I'VE DISCONTENT -- AWARENESS
WEEK KNOWN AS T. D..
AS YOU KNOW MAY AS MENTAL HEALTH
MONTH.
AS AN IMPORTANT TIME. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ONE IN FIVE U.
S. ADULTS OF WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
TODAY IS LIVING WITH SOME SORT
OF MENTAL ILLNESS.
MANY PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS CHRONIC
MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE TREATMENT
WITH ANTI -- PSYCHOTIC MEDICINE
AND MEDICATIONS.
WHILE ONGOING TREATMENT.
WITH THESE MEDICATIONS CAN BE
VERY HELPFUL.
AND EVEN LIFESAVING FOR MANY.
BUT IT ALSO LEADS TO TAR DIVE
THIS COULD END UP.
TV AS IT'S KNOWN IS A MOVEMENT
DISORDER.
THAT IS CHARACTERIZED BY RANDOM
INVOLUNTARY UNCONTROLLED
MOVEMENTS.
OF THE FACE AND BODY AND MUSCLES
THROUGHOUT A PERSON'S BODY.
THE SHAKING OF THE BODY
SOMETIMES IT MAY IMPACT THE
MUSCLES ASSOCIATED WITH WALKING
SPEECH EIGHTEEN AND EVEN
BREATHING.
TV CAN DEVELOP MONTHS YEARS OR
EVEN DECADES AFTER PERSON STARTS
TAKING THESE MEDICATIONS.
AND EVEN AFTER THEY'VE
DISCONTINUED THIS CONTINUED FOR
SOME TIME.
NOT ALL OF THESE PATIENTS
DEVELOPED TODAY BUT IT IS
DEVELOPS AND IT IS OFTEN
[inaudible]
PERMANENT.
PATIENTS SUFFERING FROM TV OFTEN
SUFFER EMBARRASSMENT DUE TO
ABNORMAL INVOLUNTARY MOVEMENTS
WHICH LEADS THEM TO WITHDRAW
FROM SOCIETY.
THESE ARE FOLKS TRIED TO LIVE
AND FUNCTION IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE LACK OF
AWARENESS OF THE DISEASE CREATES
A STIGMA.
THE MORE WE CAN RISE AND TO THE
AWARENESS OF THIS ILLNESS.
AND MORE ISSUES PERTAIN TO
MENTAL HEALTH COME FORTH THE
MORE WE CAN MOVE.
THIS TERRIBLE SIGMA AND GET
AROUND IT.
TV IS OFTEN.
UNRECOGNIZED WITH PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM THE ILLNESS
AREN'T CALMLY DOT MISDIAGNOSIS
BUT THERE ARE SOME HOPE.
AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF RESEARCH.
TWO NEW TREATMENTS FOR TV HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE FDA
PROVIDING RELIEF TO THOSE WHO
HAVE SUFFERED FROM THIS TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE DISEASE.
WE CAN NOW HOPE.
THAT MORE MORE PEOPLE.
WANT TO BECOME EDUCATED ABOUT
THE DISEASE WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
CURE IT TOTALLY.
SO WITH THIS MISTER PRESIDENT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE ON
HEARING SEEN NONE THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
SIDE OF SEE NO OBJECTION. THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP I DON'T FIFTY FIVE
SOONER DRAWS SO IF YOU'RE READY.
PASS ON FILE.
NEXT UP OF FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR
ON BURKE.
PASS ON FILE [inaudible]
SENATOR NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN SENATORS HERTZBERG.
SENATE HERTZBERG READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
DAMAGES [inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT IN. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN YOUNG FOUR YEAR
OLD BOY.
SOUGHT DAMAGES IN THE CASE
BECAUSE HE SUFFERED NEUROLOGICAL
DAMAGE AFTER LIVING IN AN
APARTMENT ILLEGALLY COATED WITH
LEAD PAINT.
WHILE THE BOY'S ATTORNEY
ESTIMATED THE CHIEF HE SHOULD BE
AWARDED. THREE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
AMOUNT HE WOULD HAVE EARNED OVER
HIS LIFETIME.
THE LANDLORDS ATTORNEY ARGUED.
THE SHOW ONLY BE AWARDED ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE AS A LOT THE YOU KNOW.
HE WAS UNLIKELY TO ATTAIN THE
ADVANCED EDUCATION THAT WOULD
GARNER THE LARGER INCOME LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN I REPEAT AS A LOT
THE NO LESS THAN HALF BECAUSE HE
WOULD NOT BE GOOD.
GARNER THOSE KINDS OF THAT KIND
OF WAGES.
THIS PRACTICE IN MY JUDGMENT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE VALUED NOT
BASED UPON THE IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS RACE OR
GENDER.
YET THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS
IN OUR COURTROOMS EVERY DAY
WHICH IS HAPPENING HERE TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA COURT ROOMS.
AND BECAUSE HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS SUCH AS
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND WOMEN IN
THE UNITED STATES OR LESS ON
AVERAGE THAN WHITE.
MAIL COULD THEIR WHITE AND MALE
COUNTERPARTS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
DAMAGE THEY RECEIVE CAN BE
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER.
THIS MEASURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WOULD MAKE OUR CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE BY
PUTTING AN END TO THIS REPUGNANT
AND WIDESPREAD PRACTICE THAT'S
HAPPENING IN COURT ROOMS RIGHT
NOW.
LEGAL DEFENDANTS TEAM SHOULD NOT
SHORT CHANGE PLAINTIFFS IN
PERSONAL INJURY WRONGFUL DEATH
CASES BASED UPON THEIR RACE AND
GENDER IN THESE CASES MEMBERS.
JUDGES AND JURIES RELY ON
CALCULATION TABLES THAT FORENSIC
ECONOMIST SENATOR VERY A
BRILLIANT ONE TESTIFIED.
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IN PASSING
THIS MEASURE THE USED TO PREDICT
THE PLAINTIFFS LOST EARNINGS AND
WAGES.
THESE TABLES ARE BASED UPON
FEDERAL CENSUS AND DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STATISTICS THAT BREAK DOWN
POTENTIAL FUTURE EARNINGS.
ALONG RACE AND GENDER LINES
BEYOND THE BIG THE INDIVIDUAL
IMPACT.
THIS INEQUITABLE REPUGNANT
PRACTICES BROUGHT REFAX I STRESS
TO FIRST PERPETUATION SYSTEMATIC
IN EQUITY TO DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
BECAUSE IT TELLS COMPANIES IF
YOU DO BAD THINGS TO POOR
COMMUNITIES WITH DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS.
YOUR FINANCIAL LIABILITY WILL BE
SMALLER.
I WANT TO READ THE BILL AND I
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
BUT I WANT TO READ THE FULL TEXT
OF THE BILL.
WHICH MAKES THE POINT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT VERY LONG MISSION RULE
TAX TO THE BILL SO SAYS AS
FOLLOWS PERMISSION TO READ WE
ALL READ WITH.
MACHINERY MISSIONARY THANK YOU.
ESTIMATIONS FROM MEASURES ARE
CALCULATION OF PAST PRESENT OR
FUTURE PERSONAL INJURY OR
WRONGFUL DEATH DAMAGES SHALL NOT
BE REDUCED.
BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY GENDER
RELIGION OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
THAT'S THE BILL LIKE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SIMPLE BROAD
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE PART OF WHO
WE ARE AND THAT WE NEED TO
UPDATE THE RULES.
OFHOW COURT ROOMS OPERATE IN
THIS COUNTRY ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
JEANNIE HEARING NONE IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
CA NINE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM.
FIFTY EIGHT SOONER CHIANG I SEE
SHE'S READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR CHIANG AN ACT RELATING
TO GENE THERAPY CUTS.
IN RETURN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
AS THE ONE EIGHTY REQUIRES THAT
ALL SELLERS OF GENE THERAPY KIDS
KNOWN AS DO IT YOURSELF CHRIS
FOR KIDS MUST INCLUDE A NOTICE
BEFORE PURCHASE AND A WARNING
LABEL.
ON THE PRODUCT TO NOTIFY
CUSTOMERS THAT THESE KIDS ARE
NOT FOR SELF ADMINISTRATION.
CRISPER CAST NINE IS A NEW GENE
EDITING TECHNOLOGY THAT OFFERS
THE POTENTIAL FOR SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT OVER OTHER GENE.
EDITING TECHNOLOGIES AND EASE OF
USE AFTER SEEING COST.
AND CRISPER IS AN ACRONYM FOR
CLUSTER REGULARLY INITIALLY
SHORT PALINDROMIC REPEATS WHICH
ARE UNIQUE DNA SEQUENCES FOUND
IN SOME BACTERIA.
AND OTHER MICROORGANISMS
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY THE
CONGRESSIONAL RESEARCH SERVICE
ON CRISPER TECHNOLOGY MANY
EXPERTS CLAIM THAT CHRIS FOR
CAST NINE TECHNOLOGY MAY OFFER
THE MEANS VERS PREVENT TREAT OR
CURE.
MEDICAL CONDITIONS SUCH AS
DIABETES MALARIA SICKLE CELL
DISEASE AND MORE HOWEVER.
THERE ARE CONCERNS WITHIN THE
SCIENCE COMMUNITY ON THE AMATEUR
USE OF THIS INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY.
THE FOR THE AFFORDABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY THESE PRODUCTS
HAVE BENEFITTED EDUCATIONAL AND
INSTITUTIONS BUT CONCERNS REMAIN
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON CONSUMER
SAFETY.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES CAUGHT ON VIDEO
OF INDIVIDUALS INJECTING
THEMSELVES WITH CRISPER CAST
NINE ENERGY.
AERIALS WITH THE INTENTION OF
EDITING THEIR PHYSIOLOGY.
SINCE THIS IS STILL A VERY NEW
TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE NEW HEALTH
RISKS EMERGING AS WE GO FORWARD.
SEVERAL ARTICLES HAVE EVEN CITED
POTENTIAL CANCER RISKS.
THERE ARE CASES IN WHICH WE
SEARCH TEAMS HAVE RECREATED
EXTINCT STRAINS OF VIRAL
DISEASES FROM SCRATCH.
THE UNITED STATES FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALREADY
STATED THAT THE SALE OF GENE
THERAPY PRODUCTS WITH THE INTENT.
OF SELF ADMINISTRATION IS GET A
IS AGAINST THE LAW AND THE
DEPARTMENT STATES CONCERNS ABOUT
SAFETY RISKS.
CONSERVE CONSUMER PROTECTION
WHEN PURCHASING THESE.
DO IT YOURSELFERS FOR KIDS SB
ONE EIGHTY REQUIRES THAT ALL
SELLERS PROVIDE A NOTICE.
ON THEIR WEBSITE THAT IS
DISPLAYED FOR THE CONSUMER PRIOR
TO THE POINT OF SALE AS WELL AS
THE LABEL ON THE PACKAGE
CONTAINING.
THE CHRIS FOR KIDS SAYING THAT
THESE CHRIS FOR KIDS ARE NOT
INTENDED FOR SELF ADMINISTRATION
WE NEED TO BE PROACTIVE WHEN IT
COMES NEW TECHNOLOGIES RATHER
THAN REACTIVE WHEN SOMEONE GETS
SERIOUSLY HURT.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
UNION SCENE AND THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
ON ITEM.
FIFTY EIGHT NO OBJECTIONS THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM.
SIXTY BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
HE'S READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO JOINT POWERS.
SOONER PORTANTINO THANK YOU I
MISSED PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS --
TODAY I PRESENT SB THREE FIFTY
FIVE WHICH WOULD ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE DESIGNATED
ALTERNATE MEMBER OF A
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A JOINT
POWERS AGENCY ALSO BE A MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A
MEMBER LOCAL AGENCY TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN A CLOSED SESSION DISCUSSION
OF THAT JP A LOCAL AGENCY
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATIVE BODIES
ARE TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO ATTEND
MEETINGS OF THEIR LEGISLATIVE
BODY MEETINGS OF SUB COMMITTEES
AND ADVISORY COMMITTEES OF THAT
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
MEETINGS OF REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
TO WHICH THAT LEGISLATIVE BODY
BIRD.
BELONGS AND LOCAL COMMUNITY
EVENTS LOCAL AGENCIES BELONG TO
A NUMBER OF JP ACE MANY OF WHICH
ADDRESS TECHNICAL ISSUE SUCH AS
INSURANCE COVERAGE AND RETAIL
ELECTRIC POWER PROCUREMENT.
IN LIGHT OF THE MANY MEETINGS
OFF ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
REQUIRED TO ATTEND AND THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES ADDRESSED BY
SOME GPAS MANY SUCH AGREEMENTS
PROVIDE FOR THAT LOCAL AGENCY
MEMBER OF THE JPA. TO DESIGNATE
AN ALTERNATE DIRECTOR THAT IS
NOT A MEMBER OF THAT LEGISLATIVE
BODY UNFORTUNATELY EXISTING LAW
PREVENTS AN ALTERNATE THAT IS
NOT A MEMBER OF THE LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODY FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE JP ACE
CLOSE SESSION DISCUSSION.
THIS BILL WOULD PERMIT SUCH AN
ELECTED ALTERNATES O
PARTICIPATE IN THE CLOSED
SESSION DISCUSSIONS OF THAT JEEP
JPA.
SUCH A CHANGE WOULD WOULD
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF JPM
MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE IS UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM THEIR
ALTERNATE CAN'T HEAR THE FIRST
HAND DISCUSSION.
AND PRECLUDES THE MEMBER FROM
GETTING THAT INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE
OF THIS CORRECTS THAT --
SITUATION A VERY NARROW FORMAT
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DESCRIPTION OF IT
ON THE ITEM.
HEARING TINA IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING A NON INTRO
CALL.
SHE NONE THE MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO HOW WE'RE
GONNA RETURN BACK TO PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOORS SENATOR PORTANTINO
I KNOW YOU HAVE INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU A MISS PRESIDENTE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR IT'S MY
HONOR TO PASADENA DAY.
MAYBE SACRAMENTO BUT IT'S A
PASADENA DAY EARLY WE HAD
PASADENA RUBBER MEMBERS OF A. K.
A. BUT I'M PROUD IN THE GALLERY
TO SEE THE PASADENA FIGHT
SUPERINTENDENT STAND UP PLEASE.
AND SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS FOR THE
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WHO ARE HERE IN THE GALLERY
[inaudible]
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE PASADENA
JUNIOR LEAGUE IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS WELL SO IT'S AN ALL
PASADENA DAY IN SACRAMENTO
PRESIDENT IS TAKING OVER THE
PLACE AND I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT.
PASADENA THE GREAT TWENTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT PLEASE GIVE A
WARM WELCOME WELCOME TO YOUR
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
TURNING BACK TO DAILY FILE WE'RE
ON ITEM SIXTY ONE SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE SHE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY THREE
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO VITAL RECORDS.
DINNER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
ONE OF THE SMALL YET IMPORTANT A
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE OF WILD
FIRES WE SAW.
WAS THAT MANY TOWNS LOST VITAL
RECORDS A VITAL RECORDS -- WHAT
A PERSON NEEDS TO GET A COPY OF
A VITAL RECORD CERTIFIED COPIES
OF THE DOCUMENT HELD THE
RECORDER'S OFFICE?
BY THE MOST REQUESTED BY MAIL IT
TAKES SEVEN TO TEN DAYS.
THIS MEASURE IS ANOTHER ONE OF
MY BLOCKCHAIN EFFORTS TO BEGIN
THE USE TECHNOLOGY AND AND
CREATE THE NECESSARY BACK UP FOR
THESE THINGS WITH LIMITED AND
HEALTH COMMITTEE TO MERIT
CERTIFICATES LAST FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITION
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NINE IT'S ELIGIBLE
FOR YOU NATURAL CALLS OR ANY
OBJECTION USING YEAH UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IN THIS I DON'T.
SEE NONE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO OKAY NEXT UP
ITEM [inaudible]
SIXTY TWO CENTER HERTZBERG.
HE'S GOING TO PASS ON FILE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU HAVE A NUMBER ITEMS THEY'RE
ON CALL SO SOON AS WE GATHER
TOGETHER GONNA START LOOKING
CALL ON THOSE ITEMS
.
MEMBERS WE'RE READY TO LIFT THE
CALL AND WE HAVE QUITE A FEW%
ITEMS SO IF YOU'RE PREPARED.
FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY BY DOCTOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS HUESO [inaudible]
HI. EIGHT ZERO THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible] FIVE HUESO
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY SIX ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI.
MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP I AM
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR HILL
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBER
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible] FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM THIRTY BY
SENATOR BATES PLEASE CALL THE
APPS A MEMBER [inaudible]
WIENER. THIRTY NINE YEAR OLD.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR HILL.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
I THIRTY THREE ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER PLEASE CALL THE
OPTION MEMBER [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP IS I'M
THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR PAN.
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
TERASA [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT.
EXCEPT ITEM THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR HUESO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible] FOR
JUST [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
WARLOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY THREE ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
BY CENTER ON BURKE PLEASE CALL
THE OPTION MEMBERS [inaudible]
JACKSON. FIVE STERN [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MIX UP I AM THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
HI WIENER.
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP ITEM
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR JONES
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible] FIVE MERLE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible] THIRTY SEVEN ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
NEXT UP.
ITEM FORTY BY SENATOR BATES.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
WIENER [inaudible]
I THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES EXCEPT.
I M FORTY ONE BY SENATOR STONE
PLEASE CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS
STERN I'M SORRY [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP ON FORTY
THREE BY CENTER OUR JULY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
EXCEPT ITEM FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JONES PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
PAN.
I BY CASTING [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
NOW. 314- THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP I'M FORTY FIVE A SINNER
HERTZBERG PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBER [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MEASURE
PASSES BACKS UP ITEM 46% --
GLAZER.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THERE ARE THERE.
I BY WIENER [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
EXCEPT FALL FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
JONES PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBER
[inaudible]
WIENER. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ITEM FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE BY SENATOR
CAFIERO PLEASE CALL THE APPS A
MEMBER [inaudible]
WIENER.
HI THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING TO CONSENT GALLAGHER
MEMBERS ARE ARE THERE ANY ITEMS
TO BE REMOVED OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENIOR NINE THEM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SIX FIFTY TWO AND SENATE BILL.
SEVEN FIFTY ONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON ARTS CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEN IN YOU SEE NINE THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED.
NOW RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND WE HAVE TO A
JOURNEY MEMORIES WE HAVE SENATOR
HILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JIM
DUNBAR A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
SAN MATEO COUNTY AND A BELOVED
RADIO AND TV PERSONALITY.
IN THE BAY AREA FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS JIM DUNBAR GREETED THE
MORNING WITH BAY AREA VIEWERS
AND LISTENERS BRINGING THEN THE
NEWS OF THE DAY TEMPERED WITH
GENTLE OBSERVATIONAL HUMOR.
JIM IS REMEMBERED FOR CHANGING
THE LANDSCAPE OF RADIO IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE JIM CAME TO KGO RADIO IN
SAN FRANCISCO THERE WERE NEWS
SHOWS AND THERE WERE TALK SHOWS
IN THE BAY AREA'S AIR WAVES.
BUT NO ONE COMBINED THE TWO JIM
DID ANY GAINED A LARGE AND LOYAL
AUDIENCE WHO HELPED TO MAKE KGO
RADIO NUMBER ONE FOR AS LONG AS
HE WAS ON THE AIR.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE JIM
BECAME THE FIRST TO SAN
FRANCISCO ON AIR PERSONALITY TO
BE INDUCTED IN THE RADIO
BROADCASTERS HALL OF FAME.
HE RETIRED IN TWO THOUSAND BUT
CONTINUED TO BE A TRUSTED VOICE
IN DISCUSSIONS OF NEWS AND
CURRENT EVENTS IN TALKS IT'S
SENIOR CENTERS WHERE HE
VOLUNTEERED.
HE ALSO WAS A FAITHFUL
PARTICIPANT IN THE ANNUAL
MEMORIAL DAY PARADE IN HILLSBORO.
AS A DRIVER AND IN MORE RECENT
YEARS AS A PASSENGER IN HIS
BEAUTIFULLY KEPT MODEL A FORD.
JIM PASSED AWAY ON EARTH DAY HE
WAS.
EIGHTY NINE JIM IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE BETH WITH WHOM HE
CELEBRATED THEIR SIXTIETH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY LAST
DECEMBER.
JIM IS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER BROOKE AND HIS SON
JAMES PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING.
BAY AREA BROADCAST PIONEER JIM
DUNBAR BY ADJOURNING IS MEMORY
THAN YOU IN THE SENATE
CONDOLENCES TO THE DUMP OUR
FAMILY AND WE WILL.
BRING THE NAME FOR IT SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALIVE RESIDENT.
EXCEPT SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- TODAY ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A LONG TIME
FRIEND OF MANY OF THE CAPITAL
TONY ROBERTS WHO PASSED AWAY
UNEXPECTEDLY FRIDAY APRIL
NINETEENTH.
HE WAS SIXTY EIGHT YEARS OLD.
THIRTY MADE HER MARK HAS A
PROMINENT POLITICAL INSIDER
RELATIONSHIP BUILDER OF WHEN SHE
ESTABLISHED A SUCCESSFUL
FUNDRAISING AND EVENT PLANNING
BUSINESS IN. NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR OVER FORTY YEARS HE
WORKED FOR LOCAL AND STATE
POLITICIANS INCLUDING THREE
SENATE LEADERS AND ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS.
A DIVERSE GROUP OF TERRIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE FIELD OF
EDUCATION WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC SAFETY THE
ARTS AND ANIMAL RIGHTS.
TONY WAS A PIONEER FOR WOMEN AT
THE TIME AS SHE STARTED HER
BUSINESS AND SPENT MANY YEARS
MENTORING YOUNG WOMAN IN THE
FUND RAISING WORLD.
BORN IN HAWTHORNE NEVADA TONY
WAS THE OLDEST OF TEN SIBLINGS
SHE BEGAN HER CAREER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO AS A VISTA VOLUNTEER
AND COMMUNITY ACTIVIST AND
EVENTUALLY MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY AFTER SERVING AS
A SENATE FELLOW AND PRESIDENT
PRO TEM -- DAVID WITH BIRDIES
OFFICE SHE JOINED A WELL
RESPECTED LOBBYING FIRM AND
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHIROPRACTIC ASSOCIATION.
ADDITION TO OUR SON JONAS AND
TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS IN PORTLAND
OREGON TONY IS ALSO SURVIVED BY
HER MOTHER AND HER SISTER.
TONY WILL BE MISSED BUT WILL BE
LOVINGLY REMEMBERED BY ALL WHO
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO KNOW
HER.
THERE WILL BE A CELEBRATION OF
LIFE HEALTH FOR HER TODAY AT
FOUR THIRTY AT A ONLY BUT A GUY
I SPEND A LOT ON EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED L. STREET.
SACRAMENTO HAS TO RETURN IN HER
MEMORY.
IN THE SENATE CONDOLENCES TO THE
ROBERTS FAMILY AND I ASK THAT
YOU BRING THE NAME FOR CHORE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE SENATE
SOONER ATKINS TO DISS CLEAR.
THIS PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR A
VERY PRODUCTIVE DAY -- I WILL
SEE YOU ALL AGAIN ON THURSDAY AT
NINE AM SHARP.
I HERE'S LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
PRODUCTIVE WEEK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
OUR MEMBERSTHAT CONCLUDES THE
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY BUT WE
WOULD ABSENT TO REMAIN ON THE
FLOOR AFTER ADJOURNMENT FOR A
GROUP FULL WHICH ARE GREEN.
DIRE ARE SHAWL FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH DAY SO WE STAND ADJOURNED